MAKE SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS
TODAY- TO YET AGAIN EXPLAINED
THE PROCESS SEES IT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
WHILE I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR
THOSE THAT MIGHT BE TUNING IN
FOR THE FIRST TIME. SO MANY
COVER THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF
THINGS FOR TODAY. IN RESPONSE
TO COBIT NINETEEN A MERCHANT
SEE TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF. WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING.
AS MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS
TO NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS TO OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. BY CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. SO FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN. IT'S THEIR RIGHT
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. NINE TWO FOUR ONE FOUR
FIVE EIGHT AND UNDOUBTEDLY WE
WILL REPEAT THIS AS WE GO
THROUGH THE HEARING SO YOU HAVE
THAT INFORMATION BEFORE YOU
ANOTHER TIME OR TWO. WHEN WE DO
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY WILL OPEN YOUR
LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE THAT YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
US YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE MIGHT NOT
BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU SO AGAIN WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY.
AND ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IN AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LEAD TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO OUR
NEW ONLINE TOOLS SO AGAIN WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. WE
DO WANT EVERYONE TO BE HEARD.
AND ALSO FOR OUR INCREDIBLE
STENOGRAPHER. I WANT TO ASK OUR
ALL SPEAKERS INCLUDING MY
COLLEAGUES AND WITNESSES ALIKE
TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY AND
IF I HAVE TO STOP YOU PLEASE
UNDERSTANDIT SO THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO CAPTURE YOUR TESTIMONY.
AND THAT SHE IS ABLE TO CAPTURE
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING AS YOU SPEAK.
SO MADAM SECRETARY AT THIS
POINT ARTLESS STABLISH A
QUORUM AND ADD TO MY COLLEAGUES
YOU'LL NEED TO TURN YOUR
MICROPHONE EVERY ON EVERY TIME
YOU SPEAK AND SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. GROWTH HERE ROLE HERE
HERTZBERG YEAH HERTZBERG HERE
LAYERED HERE LAYERED HERE BATES
BATES HERE ATKINS HERE ATKINS
HERE. SO I AM GOING TO SEE IF
WE CAN DISPENSE WITH SOME ITEMS
AHEAD OF OUR APPOINTEES WHO
WERE REQUIRED TO APPEAR AND SO
WHAT I WOULD ASK IS IF- A
SENATOR WOULD BE WILLING TO
MAKE A MOTION FOR ITEM NUMBER
THREE SO MOVED THANK YOU AN
ITEM NUMBER THREE IS APPOINTEES
NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR. THAT
WOULD BE MONIQUE MOYER MEMBER
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
WATER EMERGENCY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
OF MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU
CALL THE ROLL. THROUGH ROGUE
PROVIDER AYE HERTZBERG AYE
LAYERED HI THERE I BATES ALL
RIGHT IT'S AYE ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE LET ME ALSO GO AHEAD
AND ASK FOR A MOTION ON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR THANK YOU MR
MAJORITY LEADER AND THAT IS THE
BILL REFERRALS- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BOTH HI
ROTH AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE
LAYERED AYE. AYE BATES ALL
RIGHT EIGHT I ATKINS. A SECOND
HIGH I WILL PROVIDE YOU COLLEGE
PROGRAM. I DID OKAY. I YEAH I
HEARD THE ATKINS SOONER IT
THREW ME FOR A LOOP BECAUSE I'M
USED TO THAT'S OKAY- BUT WE'RE
WE'RE GOOD HI HERTZBERG FORGOT.
THERE WE GO OKAY THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GO TO
TODAY'S GOVERNOR APPOINTEES
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEMS- ONE
A. AND ONE B. WE WILL TAKE
TOGETHER AND THAT'S TO MEMBERS
OF THE INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATING GOVERNING BOARD. AND
I WANT TO TRY VERY HARD TO MAKE
SURE I GET YOUR NAMES CORRECT
PLEASE FORGIVE ME IF I DO NOT.
I WANNA WELCOME MR ASH JOSH BAG
WHAT AND MISS ANGELINA. GALLERY
TO. AND IF I GOT YOUR NAME
WRONG PLEASE CORRECT ME BECAUSE
I SHOULD ALWAYS BE IN THE
PROCESS OF LEARNING. SO LET ME
SAY WELCOME TO YOU BOTH. WE'RE
GONNA TAKE YOUR INTRODUCTIONS
FIRST BEGINNING WITH MR BAG
WHAT AND THEN FOLLOWED BY MS
YOU GO LEVY. GOOD DELETED FIVE
THANK YOU YES SO MY GOAL BY THE
END OF THIS HEARING IS TO GET
YOUR NAME ACCURATE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR I APPRECIATE
YOUR INDULGENCE IN YOUR YOUR
PATIENCE. OKAY WE WILL LET EACH
OF YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELF- AND
ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE THERE WITH
YOU THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE WHO'VE SUPPORTED YOU
AND THEN MAKE YOUR COMMENTS ARE
AND THEN WE WILL GO RIGHT TO
MEMBERS OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS SO.
MR BACK WHAT YOU GO RIGHT AHEAD.
THANK YOU CENTER OF CHECK INS
MISTER BATES SENATORS- THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING MY
NOMINATION TO THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHER SO. BOARD OF GOVERNORS
AND FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS I WANT TO TAKE
A BRIEF OPPORTUNITY TO
INTRODUCE MYSELF. MY NAME IS
AKASH FONG WHAT. I AM AS YOU
MAY KNOW A LAW PROFESSOR DOWN
THE STREET AT UC DAVIS. AND
SPENT THE LAST QUARTER OF A
CENTURY STUDYING AND TEACHING
ADMINISTRATIVE AND REGULATORY
LAW. AS WELL AS CONSTITUTIONAL.
THE WORK I'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO AS A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA ISO BOARD HAS
BEEN FRANKLY IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY OF A LIFETIME. I'VE
BEEN STUDYING THESE PATTERSON
THESE ISSUES ON ACT AS AN
ACADEMIC FOR MY ENTIRE ADULT
LIFE IN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPLEMENT TO MAKE REAL. IS
POLICIES IS. FRANKLY BEEN
ENORMOUS. IT WANT BEST THINGS
IN LIFE AND TO THANK YOU FOR-
THINGS MOVING FORWARD. FIRST
AND FOREMOST I SO IS AT HEART
RELIABILITY AND- WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR KEEPING THE
LIGHTS ON. EVENTS IN CALIFORNIA
LAST SUMMER AND ESPECIALLY THE
RECENT TRAGIC EVENTS IN TEXAS
DEMONSTRATE JUST HOW IMPORTANT
THAT ROLE IS AND I CAN PROMISE
COMMITTED TO DOING EVERYTHING
IN MY POWER TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE READY THE SORTS OF
CLIMATE EVENTS THAT CALIFORNIA
WILL BE FACING NEXT SUMMER. AND
GOING FORWARD. IN ADDITION THE
AYE SO IS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE REST OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. EMPLOYMENT SOME OF
THE MOST AMBITIOUS CLEAN ENERGY
POLICIES IN THE WORLD. THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS WORK IS
BECOMING MORE AND MORE OBVIOUS
AS WE SEE INCREASED CLIMATE
EVENTS. AND MY DEDICATION TO
SUCCESSFULLY ACHIEVING
CALIFORNIA'S GOALS. WHILE
MAINTAINING RELIABILITY IS
ABSOLUTE. WE ARE IN THE NEXT
FEW YEARS ENTERING INTO A
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING BUT
ALSO IMPORTANT AND EXCITING
TIMES AS WE DRAW CLOSER TO
ACHIEVING AGGRESSIVE RTS GOALS.
AND START THINKING HARD ABOUT
HOW TO MOVE FORWARD TOWARDS A
CARBON FREE ENERGY FUTURE. I
VERY MUCH WANT TO BE PART OF
THAT PROCESS AND CONVERSATION
WOULD BE DELIGHTED IF YOU WERE
WILLING TO GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GO AHEAD
MISS GALLAGHER. I'M GONNA TRY
AGAIN. GALLET EVER. ELIZABETH
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE MY TWO
CHILDREN WERE HERE WITH ME- MY
DAUGHTER ISABELLA. WHO IS
PROBABLY GOING TO BE ONE OF THE
FUTURE ENERGY LEADERS IN THE
WORLD YOU'RE STILL TWO TIMES
BEFORE SHE ALWAYS COMES WITH ME
CONFIRMATION. AND MY SON
NICHOLAS. WHO WAS ALSO HERE AND
WAS PROBABLY GOING TO ENSURE
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A LOT OF.
YEARS BECAUSE HE RUNS MULTIPLE
SCREENS AND DEVICES ALL AT THE
SAME TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO INTRODUCE THEM. THANK YOU
THAT'S A HIGHLIGHT OF OUR OF A
HEARING WHEN WE GET TO MEET.
PARTICULARLY YOUNG BRIGHT MINDS
THANK YOU GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. MORE MEMBERS IT IS OUR
RELIABLE GRAND AND TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
MEET OUR AMBITIOUS ENERGY. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS IN A
RELIABLE. RESILIENT AND COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER EVERY HOUR
EVERY SINGLE DAY THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE DAYS A YEAR
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS I'M EXCITED TO
CONTINUE WORKING TOWARDS MAKING
THE BRAND MORE RELIABLE
HARNESSING A DIVERSE PORTFOLIO
RESOURCE. FOCUSED NOT ONLY ON
SOLAR ENERGY BUT ALSO WENT ON
SHORE AND OFF SHORE JIM CARMEL
BIOMASS HYDRO POWER AND
STORAGE. OR AT THE SAME TIME AS
MENTIONS WE ALL HAVE SEEN THAT
WE CANNOT TAKE REGARD PROGRAMS
AN ACCOMPLISHMENT OF THE FACT
THAT UNEXPECTED AND SOMETIMES
UNFORESEEABLE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
OPERATIONAL FISHES FOR THE CAR.
RELIABILITY IS OUR PRIMARY
OBJECTIVE AND IS BOARD CHAIR I
WILL FOCUS ON ENSURING THAT THE
ISO MANAGEMENT AND THE BOARD
CONTINUES TO WORK WITH ALL
RELEVANT PARTIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS. TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THE GREAT EVENTS WE
EXPERIENCED LAST SUMMER
RESULTING IN ROLLING BLACKOUTS
NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN. ALONG WITH
A DIVERSE RESOURCE PORTFOLIO AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
OPERATING A RELIABLE GRANT
WHILE MAINTAINING ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP IS
BETTER REGIONAL COOPERATION. AS
YOU MAY KNOW THE CALIFORNIA ISO
LAUNCHED THE REAL TIME ENERGY
IMBALANCEMARKET REFERRED TO AS
THE YAYA IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
WHICH BY ALL ACCOUNTS HAS BEEN
A VERY SUCCESSFUL INITIATIVES
RESULTING IN OVER ONE POINT TWO
BILLION IN SAVINGS AND OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND METRIC
TONS OF CO TWO REDUCTIONS
ACROSS THE WEST WHILE IMPROVING
RELIABILITY AND INTEGRATION OF
RENEWABLE. MARKET NOW COVERS
THE STATE AND OVER EIGHTY. OF
THE WESTERN WORLD. WE'RE
CURRENTLY THE PROCESS OF FINE
TUNING ADDITIONAL MARKET DESIGN
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WILL BRING
GREAT. THE CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
PARTICIPANTS. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE'RE DOING ALL
THIS WHILE MAINTAINING
CALIFORNIA I ASSUME BOARD
LEADERSHIP. THURSDAY JUNE
MARKET IS VERY IMPORTANT
INITIATIVE FOR ENSURING
RELIABILITY IN WHICH I AM
DEEPLY AND PERSONALLY INVOLVED
AS THE BOARD REPRESENTATIVE ON
THE E. I AM GOVERNANCE REVIEW
COMMITTEE. I'M ALSO LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE ICE
ON ANOTHER RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS TO IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD NABLE
BETTER INTEGRATION OF LOCAL
CALIFORNIA GROWN RESOURCES.
SUCH AS ENERGY EFFICIENCY
DEMAND RESPONSE AND CUSTOMER
CALLED BEHIND THE METER
TECHNOLOGIES INCLUDING
DISTRIBUTED SOLAR STORAGE AND
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. THESE
INITIATIVES AND TECHNOLOGIES
WILL HELP US HARNESS LOCAL
RESOURCES TO IMPROVE THE
RESILIENCY AND RELIABILITY BOTH
OUR COMMUNITIES AND THE GRANT.
A LONG PERSONAL GOAL HAS BEEN
TO THE US SOLICITOR AND
INTERNATIONAL LEADER IN
RELIABLY INTEGRATING
RENEWABLES. I AM PROUD TO
REPORT THAT THE ISO IN
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP IN THIS
AREA IS WIDELY RECOGNIZED ON A
GLOBAL SCALE. IN FACT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN
REPRESENTATIVES FROM OVER A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY COUNTRIES
HAVE MET FOR THE ARE TEAM. TO
LEARN FROM OUR EXPERIENCE ALSO
IN TWENTY TWENTY THE ISO WAS
ELECTED TO PRESIDE OVER THE
GULF FIFTEEN ORGANIZATION.
WHICH IS THE WORLD'S LARGEST
ORGANIZATION OPERATORS THIS IS
A TESTAMENT. OF OUR STANDING ON
A GLOBAL SCALE. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU TO ENSURE
THAT THE CALIFORNIA ISO
CONTINUES TO BE A SHINING
EXAMPLE OF OPERATIONAL
EXCELLENCE. AND THAT WE ARE
READY TO TAKE ON THE FUTURE AND
PROVIDE RELIABLE SERVICE JUST
FOR ALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS IN THE OPENINGS I'M
GONNA GIVE SENATOR BATES A
BREAK FOR ONCE AND- LOOK TO THE
MAJORITY LEADER OVER THERE TO
START AND I'M SURE HE HAS QUITE
A NUMBER OF COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. THIS IS A AEROSPACE
MADAM OF PROTEST AND I JUST
WANT TO. RECORD TO SAY THAT-
FOR ONE OF THE- INDIVIDUALS ARE
CONSIDERING ANGELA NEGLECT OF
I'VE KNOWN HER FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS IN MY PREVIOUS
RENEWABLE ENERGY. EXPERIENCE I
AM DEEPLY YOU KNOW WE TALKED
YOU MENTIONED BOTH ABOUT
RELIABILITY OF THE GRID AND
RELIABLE SERVICES FOR ALL. IN
THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD WITH
BOTH OF YOU IN PREPARATION FOR
THIS HEARING TODAY. I WANTED TO
GIVE YOU STRESS FOR THE RECORD
ON THE ONE HAND AND ALSO TO GET
YOUR BOTH. THE PROFESSORA
BHAGWAT AND- IF CHAIR GO A-
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS BECAUSE I
AM. DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
ISSUE OF RELIABILITY WE HAVE
WORKED A LOT AS WE SEEK TO
TRANSITION. R. GRADE FROM THE
OLD ONE BASED UPON COAL AND
NATURAL GAS AND TO SOME EXTENT-
HYDROPOWER FRED KEWLEY- TO. TO
YOU KNOW A RENEWABLE GREEN
SOURCES BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE A
RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROVIDER OF
LAST RESORT CENTER PROCUREMENT
ALL OF THESE DYNAMICS. AS WE
FACE IS YOU BOTH MENTIONED
THESE EXTREME CLIMATE EVENTS
LAST YEAR DESPITE PEOPLE'S
JUDGMENT WE FACED SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES IN PROVIDING THAT
RELIABILITY IT'S HARD FOR US
TO. DETERMINE THAT BOTH WITH
RESPECT TO THE TRANSITIONS AND
HAVING BACK UP POWER IN
BATTERIES THAT ONLY LAST A FEW
HOURS AND ALL OF THE OTHER
ISSUES AND TECHNOLOGICAL ISSUES
THAT WE'RE FACING SO I WANTED
TO. SEE IF EITHER OF THE BOTH
OF YOU HAD SOME COMMENTS IN
THAT REGARD BECAUSE I AM
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED AS YOU
TALK TO THE BEST EXPERTS IN
CLIMATE THAT WE'RE GONNA FACE
SIGNIFICANT. HE CHALLENGES COME
OCTOBER NOVEMBER. EVENT THAT
COULD HAVE A VERY SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON RELIABILITY. AND
THERE'S ALSO A WHOLE HOST OF
OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE DEALING
WITH TRYING TO CONVERT THE-
GRID TO BE MORE GREENER THAN
CONFUSE ME PROCUREMENT TO BE
MORE GREEN. AND SOME OF THOSE
CHALLENGES IF YOU CAN JUST- A
TELL ME WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE
WITH RESPECT TO THOSE RISKS.
AND BE WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN
YOUR JUDGE IT WOULD YOU SHOULD
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING. TO
ENSURE THAT AND I JUST FINALLY
WANT TO MAKE THE POINT. AND YOU
COULD ADDRESS THIS THAT THE
MANAGEMENT OF OUR- ELECTRONS IF
YOU WILL OR POWER IN COULD
INCLUDE NATURAL GAS AND OTHERS.
IS QUITE CHALLENGING BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE ENERGY COMMISSION WE
HAVE THE ENERGY IMBALANCE
MARKET WE GOT THE WESTERN
REGIONAL GREAT WE'VE GOT YOU
WE'VE GOT THE P. YOU SEE. AND
HOW DO YOU SEE OUR ABILITY TO
WADE THROUGH THIS IF YOU EIGHTY
THINK I'M CORRECTED IF I AM
WHAT DO YOU WHAT DO YOU DO TO
FIX IT. SO I. HAVE TO TAKE A
FIRST SHOT SO I'M GONNA I THINK
REPEAT SOMETHINGS THAT ENTERING
THE SENATE EARLIER WHICH I
FULLY AGREE WITH. WHICH IS OF
COURSE I'M WORRIED ABOUT
RELIABILITY I THINK EVERYONE IS
AND IT'S OUR PRIMARY JOB YEAH
SO. AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHAT HAPPENED NEXT LAST
AUGUST DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN- I
THINK WE'VE LEARNED SOME
IMPORTANT LESSONS ONE OF WHICH
IS. THE STORAGE CLEAN THINKING
ABOUT RELIABILITY THE FOCUS HAS
ALWAYS BEEN ON MID AFTERNOON ON
HOT DAYS. WE'VE LEARNED THAT
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH YOU NEED TO
BE FOCUSING. FIRST OF ALL ON
IT'S LATER IN THE EVENING.
WHICH IS WHEN WE RAN INTO
TROUBLE BUT REALLY WE NEED TO
BE FOCUSING TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
THREE SIXTY FIVE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE IT'S NO LONGER. THE
WAY BUSINESS WAS DONE IN THE
PAST IS NOT THE WAY IT'S GONG
TO BE DONE IN THE FUTURE. AND
WHAT THAT MEANS ABOVE ALL ELSE
AGAIN COMPETING WITH ANGEL IN
THE SENTENCE. WE NEED TO HAVE A
MUCH MORE DIVERSE PORTFOLIO OF
RESOURCES WE NEED TO BE
FOCUSING ON THAT. GOING
FORWARD. THAT IS NOT WITHIN OUR
AUTHORITY AS THE HI SO
PRIMARILY THAT IS PRIMARILY THE
CPC'S AUTHORITY. BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE REALLY
WORKED HARD ON AND REALLY.
PUSHING TO WORK HARD CURRENTLY
GOING FORWARD IS. PRECISELY AS
YOU MENTIONED CENTER THERE ARE
A LOT OF AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY ACROSS THE CDC. AND
THE CPSC AND WE HAVE TO BE
WORKING IN COORDINATION. WE
HAVE TO BE GIVING LOTS AND LOTS
OF INPUT. INTO THE CPSC'S
PROCUREMENT PROCESS TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHT
MIX OF RESOURCE. I THINK A LOT
ANGELES. THANK YOU MUCH AND YOU
WE ARE. TO A NEW GRAD AND WE
OPTIONS. TO RENEW. AND WE SEE
IT EVERY DAY THAT THE GRANT IS
BECOMING MORE DISTRIBUTED.
MODERN VERSIFIED. WANTED
CARBONIZED MORE DIGITIZED AND
MORE DEMOCRATIZED. AND ALL
RESOURCES NEED TO REFLECT
OPTIONS SO WE CANNOT STRESS
ENOUGH THE NEED FOR DIFFERENT
RESOURCES SO WE HAVE A VERY
PORTFOLIO AND WE ARE NOT.
STROLLER CENTRIC OVERLY
DEPENDENT ON ONE RESOURCE WHICH
CAN CAUSE PROBLEMS ESPECIALLY
WITH FLEXIBILITY AT THE END OF
THE DAY. WHEN WE NEED VERY FAST
RAMPING IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THAT EVENING OKAY. AND
WHICH IS WHERE OUR
VULNERABILITY. SO CLIMATE
CHANGE YES THAT IS AN ISSUE AND
WE NEED TO BE FOCUSED ON MAKING
SURE THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE
FORESEEABLE CHANGES. AND BE
READY TO WITHSTAND MUCH MORE
FREQUENT AND HARDER HE WAY.
ACTUALLY INCOME PASSED THE
GREATER WEST. WHAT WAS REALLY
DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS HUGE STORM
THAT WE EXPERIENCED LAST YEAR
WHICH IS ONE ZERO THIRTY FIVE
OR FIFTY OR AT LATIMES. DOT A
CARD YET WE HAD A ONCE IN A TEN
YEAR EVENT ON THE GRANT STILL
WE HAVE A LOT MORE WORK TO DO.
BECAUSE THE HEAT WAVE YEAH.LAS
VEGAS IN WASHINGTON. OREGON AND
YOU HAD A REDUCE SOME OF THE
AVAILABLE RESOURCES THAT MORE
OF THE GRANT. AND WE ALSO
RELIED ON RESOURCES TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT. NUMBER FOUR
FLEXIBILITY AT THE END OF THE
DAY. THAT ACTUALLY NEEDED TO
RAMP UP FASTER ARM. SO THESE
ARE ISSUES THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED WE WORKED TOGETHER
WITH THE AGENCIES AND THAT'S
ACTUALLY. THE I SO THE CC. YOU
SEE THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
AND THE WATER BOARD NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER ALONG WITH ALL OF
THE LOAD SERVING ENTITIES SUCH
AS THE UTILITIES. INVESTOR ALL
PUBLICLY OWNED AND THE STREETS
CA. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES TO MEET THE
EVENING PEAK SO STAY IN THE
EVENING PEAK IN ALL CONDITIONS.
AND BE PREPARED FOR ALL FOR
SCALABLE CLIMATE. CHANGES THAT
CAN OCCUR AND ALSO TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN. TRY TO BE
PREPARED FOR THE- OF COURSE YOU.
WE HAVE A- WE HAVE A PLAN SEAT.
AND THERE'S GREAT OPERA. MANUAL
TO OFFER WE USED TO HOW TO
FIGHT. WITH THE NO AND WE'VE
HAD TO DO IT. WHETHER IT'S THE
ARE STILL OFFER OPEN THAT WE TO
WORK UP AND TOGETHER ACROSS
BOARD. QUICKLY TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE RELIABLE. OR WITH A
STRUCTURE. SO X. YOUR NEXT. IS
DREAM OF GAME MAIN REAL. AND WE
CALL TO BE A SLIGHT. AS
POSSIBLE AND AS- VISION TO WORK
THE FUTURE AS POSSIBLE TO FOR
THE- OF DEATH. NOT TO MAKE
MISTAKES OF MESSING WATCH WE
SHOULD HAVE CITY. MANAGER CLASS
BEFORE QUESTION. THANK YOU I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT OVER BUT
ALSO WANTED ABOUT. THIS ISSUE
OF THE ON FOR. MY UNDERSTANDING
IN THE SUBJET AREA IS THAT ARE
RESOURCE ADEQUACYHAS BEEN
THIN. THAT WONDER 15% THAT TO
THE EXTENT LIKE WE SAW LAST
YEAR YOU KNOW WHAT WHEN THE
DOCTOR BHAGWAT SAID YOU KNOW
HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE THAT WHAT
HAPPENED LAST AUGUST DOESN'T
HAPPEN WELL IT WAS
UNFORESEEABLE. AND THE REASON
WE HAVE THE PROBLEM AND FROM
WHAT I'VE TO IN TALKING TO YOUR
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. IS BECAUSE-
WE DIDN'T HAVE SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCE ADEQUACY. AND SO WE
DID WE WEREN'T PREPARED TO LOOK
FOR THE UNFORESEEABLE AND WHAT
WE KNOW FROM CLIMATE EXTREME
CLIMATE CONDITIONS. AND
PARTICULARLY WHAT WE THINKING
ABOUT THE WAY ON WHAT
PERCENTAGE IT IS THAT WE HAVE
TO PREPARE FOR THAT. BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA CAMP IN A POSITION
WHERE LIGHTS GO ON AGAIN. SO MY
QUESTION IS TWO THINGS ONE.
WHAT WHAT HOMEWORK HAVE YOU
DONE WITH RESPECT TO
COORDINATING WE MUST COORDINATE
OKAY DID YOU DO IT. WHAT HAS IT
BEEN IMPROVE WITH RESPECT TO
THE ENERGY COMMISSION IN THE
PEAK STEEP THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. IF
THE ANSWER IS YES TO HAVE YOU
INCREASED YOUR RESOURCE
ADEQUACY TO BE ABLE TO BE
PREPARED FOR THE UNFORGETTABLE
BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
YOU'RE GONNA GET. BEING
PREPARED FOR THE UNFORESEEABLE
WANTED TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THOSE THINGS AND I GUESS THE
THIRD POINT IS. YOU KNOW I JUST
THINK WE NEED IS A LEGISLATURE
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BE HAPPY ABOUT THIS
AND I HAVEN'T DISCUSSES WITH
PROTERRA. BUT MUCH MORE
OVERSIGHT BECAUSE WE KEEP THE
RISK IS JUST TOO HIGH TO ALL OF
US. IN ENSURING THAT WE DON'T
SEE THESE SITUATIONS AGAIN. IF
YOU CAN JUST GIVE US SOME
REACTIONS ON THOSE I'D
APPRECIATE. I THINK I CAN SPEAK
TO THE I. SEVEN THAT WE AREWE
WELCOME DIALOGUE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ALL TYPES- AND
THAT'S- AND I THINK. MANAGEMENT
WOULD AGREE WITH THAT EVERYONE
WOULD AGREE WITH THAT
ABSOLUTELY A PARTNERSHIP. WE
ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE CPC OF OURS IS A PART TIME
BOARD BUT THE CLEAR. HAVE BEEN
STRONGLY PUSHING THE STAFF AND
THEY HAVE BEEN ACTING. WORKING
HARD I THINK THERE HAS BEEN
PROGRESS AND THAT THE CPC.
AFRICAN UNDERSTAND NOW WHAT THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE ARE- WE ARE.
AYE SO FOR EXAMPLE IS
ADVOCATING THAT THE CPUC REYES.
THE RESERVE MARGIN FROM FIFTEEN
TO SEVENTEEN AND A HALF
PERCENT. PRECISELY IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT IN SIGHT.
WE ALSO I THINK NEED TO DO
SOMETHING THAT I ACTUALLY HAVE.
MENTIONED I'M GONNA LET HER
CONTRAST WORK IN MORE DETAIL.
WHICH IS WE HAVE TO FOCUS. ON
NOT THE TRADITIONAL AFTERNOON
PEAK BUT IN THE EVENING WHEN
THE SUN IS DOWN HOW WE CAN
MANAGE TO MAINTAIN THE FACT
THAT DURING A HEAT WAVE. PEOPLE
DO NOT TURN OFF THE AIR
CONDITIONING JUST BECAUSE THE
SUN HAS GONE DOWN IT REMAINS
HOT- AND THAT IS CERTAINLY VERY
VERY MUCH OUR FOCUS. AND I
THINK. ALL COURT ENTITIES IN
CALIFORNIA OUR PRIMARY. SIMPLY
FOCUS BETWEEN NOW AND NEXT
SUMMER IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO ADDRESS THIS YOUR CONF VERY
REASONABLE CONCERNS. AND THANK
YOU FOR RAISING THOSE ISSUES
SENATOR HERTZBERG WE ARE VERY
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WORKING
TOGETHER WITH YOU SEE IN THE
CITY'S G. I'M HAPPY TO REPORT
AND WE HAVE- I'M GOING MEETINGS
WITH SHE SHE YOU SEE AN ISO
METER SHOP ON BOARD LEVEL AS
WELL. TO TALK ABOUT ISSUES
WHERE WE CAN WORK TOGETHER IN
ORDER TO INSURE THAT WE HAVE
ALIGNMENT PROGRAMS AND
INCENTIVES AND THAT WE'RE ALL
WORKING TOWARDS THE SAME GOAL
WITH THE SAME OBJECTIVES. ARE
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE ALSO
NEED TO BE AWARE OFF WITH THE
EVENING BECAUSE ASH MENTIONED.
IS HAVING MORE RESOURCES THAT
ALLOW US TO MEET THE EVENING
PEAK AND WE HAVE CERTAINLY
ACHIEVED UP TO A LARGE EXTENT
WITH EXTENDING THE ONE
STRUGGLING. WE DON'T WANT TO
RETIRE PLANS AHEAD OF TIME
BEFORE WE HAVE TECHNOLOGIES TO
REPLACE THEM WITH ANY OF THE
SAME TIME WE ARE ALSO
INSTALLING MORE STORAGE ON THE
GRID. IN FACT I WAS AT THE
RIBBON CUTTING CEREMONY VIRTUAL
LIKE THIS ONE- EARLIER THIS
WEEK- IN LONG BEACH HERE ARE
WITH A YES WHERE WE UNVEILED A
HUNDRED. A HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF
STORAGE FACILITY CUTTING EDGE
THE WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE HOW
ARE FOR FOUR HOURS CONTINUOUSLY
SO SUCH TECHNOLOGIES THAT ALLOW
US TO BETTER OPERATE THE
GREATER VERY IMPORTANT. AND I
BELIEVE THAT NOT WE HAVE ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS ON THE
GROUND WE WILL HAVE OVER
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED MEGAWATTS BY
THE SUMMER WHICH SHOULD HELP US
WIDE SUBSTANTIALLY. IN MEETING
THAT EVENING RAIMES AND
ENSURING THAT WE CAN RELIABLY
OPERATE THE GRANT ESPECIALLY IN
THE EXTREME CONDITIONS. THAT
RAMP IS GOING TO CONTINUE IT IS
INITIAL FOR US THAT WE MEET
WITH GAS. IMPORTS WILL MEET
WITH STORAGE WE NEED TO ENHANCE
FLEXIBILITY WENEED TO PULL
DEMAND ENERGY RESOURCES AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE AND WE NEED TO
INCENTIVIZE CUSTOMERS THAT OWN
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS- PERSONAL
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES EVEN
ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A MARKET THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO SUPPORT THE
GRANT. AND MONETIZE THEIR
INCENTIVES. BECAUSE BLACKS
ORIGIN GREAT AND WE LOVE THEM
AND WE NEED MORE OF THAT. BUT
WE ALSO KNEW TO BE ABLE TO
MARKET BECAUSE- PER. SO IT
SHOULD ALL HAVE ON THAT. VERY
CLOSE FOR. TO ENSURE THAT WE-
RELY ALL OF TO GROW. THE OURS
OUR ECONOMY. MAINTAIN OUR
INVITE. AND I COME LEADERS.
PROVIDE YOU WHICH IS GOOD FOR
THE- WITH THESE TO COME. AS WE-
BUT MOST ALL OPERATE RELIABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT. BECAUSE
MAKE ONE FINAL POINT OKAY YEAH
I THINK IT'S A IMPORTANT IT
REALLY CONCERNS ME. YOU KNOW
BACK WHEN WE HAD THE ENERGY
CRISIS AND WALLY MCGUIRE WAS
RUNNING. HE REMEMBER HIM HE WAS
WRITING FLEXURE POWER THE
MESSAGE WE WERE SENDING
EVERYBODY IS TURN YOUR WASHER
YOUR DRYER OFF DURING THE DAY.
AND DO IT AT NIGHT WHEN THE
LOAD WAS DOWN NOW BECAUSE WE
HAVE SOLAR AND SOMETIMES WHEN
DURING THE DAY WE'RE GETTING A
GREATER ELEMENT OF POWER THE
DUCK CURVE AND ALL THOSE
ISSUES. AND SO NOW WE'VE GOT
THE LOAD RAMP AT NIGHT. THE
BUILDING I WOULD I JUST WANT TO
PUT ON THE RECORD THAT I
MENTION TO BOTH OF YOU THAT I
THINK IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
FOR YOU TO WATCH WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE ISSUE RESOURCE ADEQUACY.
ED AND YOU KNOW THIS A CHAIR
GLIB TO VOTE BUT FROM FROM YOUR
EXPERIENCE AND I KNOW THAT FROM
WORKING WITH YOU. THAT SOLAR
SILICON BASED SOLAR STARTS TO
DEGRADE AT SEVENTY SEVEN
DEGREES. ARE THERE SOME
EXPECTATIONS FROM OUR EXPERTS
HERE IN THE SENATE WITH WHOM WE
CONSULTED WITH STAFF BEFORE
THIS HEARING TO HELP PREPARE
THAT THEY EXPECT IS WE COULD
HAVE TEMPERATURES MUCH AS A
HUNDRED TWENTY DEGREES. SO NOW
YOU HAVE THE MID DAY YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE TRYING TO PREPARE
FOR THE EVENING RAMP WITH THE
EXPECTATION YOU'RE RUNNING
ELECTRONS DURING THE DAY. AND
THAT COULD BE SHUTTING DOWN
BECAUSE THE POWER THAT YOU'RE
SICK YOU'RE RELYING ON WHICH
HAS BEEN PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY
AND SOLAR WILL DRAMATICALLY BE
REDUCED WHICH FURTHER THAN PUTS
US AT RISK FOR BLACKOUTS AND I
JUST. YOU KNOW ONLY RAISE THIS
BECAUSE WE FROM OUR EXPERTS AND
THE STAFF THAT WE'VE TALKED TO
A CONSULTED WITH IN THE SENATE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
PREPARED BECAUSE WE CAN'T TAKE
THIS RISK I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY SHORE MAKE ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
THAT CLEAR. WHEN THE HOMEWORK
THAT WE'VE. DONE HERE WITH OUR
OWN. OF PEOPLES. YES IT I'M
ABSOLUTELY. ANYBODY JUST ADD WE
NEED TO BE. WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
INCREASING TEMPERATURES AND WE
MAY SEE VARIATION NOT ONLY IN
SEOUL. SOLAR MAY REACH. YOUR
FOUR BY 10% OR- MORE DEPENDING
ON THE TEMPERATURES AND WE SEE
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DEGREES IN RIYADH IN THE DESERT
AND OTHER LOCATIONS. WIND
DOESN'T ALWAYS BLOW I MEAN WE
WHAT WE COULD HAVE A CLOUD
COVER. AND ALSO WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE THEY MAY BE A REDUCTION
IN HARD RESOURCES WHICH WE
DEPEND ON FROM THE PACIFIC
NORTHWEST. SO WE ARE TAKING ALL
THIS INTO ACCOUNT. AND ENSURING
THAT WE BOUGHT ALL THE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE. AND ALL
OF THE RESOURCES STOCK IN ORDER
SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE. THAT
WE'VE GOT ENOUGH ON THE BREAD.
TO PROVIDE RELIABLE SERVICE
THROUGH THOSE DIFFICULT THANKS.
AND I'M TAKING CLIMATE CHANGE
INTO ACCOUNT. IT'S GOING TO
AFFECT ALL OF US. THANK YOU
THANK YOU- AND SENATOR YOU NOT
IF YOU HAVE OTHER. LATER WILL
COME BACK TO YOU THIS IS
IMPORTANT CENTER GROVE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU BOTH
OF YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY I'M
SORRY WE DIDN'T HAD CONNECT A
YESTERDAY BUT I FIGURED WHAT I
HAD TO. ASK WOULD BE SIMPLE TO
THEM. TO RESPOND TO I DO HAVE
THE SAME CONCERNS IT- THE
MAJORITY LEADER HAS. OVER THIS
ISSUE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
TURNING THE I SO WHEN I WAS SO
IMPRESSED. WITH EVERYTHING AND
HOW IT OPERATES AND- GOSH ALL
THE DIGITAL SCREENS AND
EVERYTHING THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
THEIR- IT WAS FRANKLY WAY OVER
MY HEAD BUT I DID UNDERSTAND
ONE THING THE DUCK CURVE THAT
WAS- DESCRIBED AS AN IT TALKED
ABOUT THE RAMP UP PERIOD THAT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE. AND HOW
RAMPING UP IN THE EVENING IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WHEN THIS
DISCUSSION WAS TAKING PLACE
WAS. SEVERELY DIFFICULT TO
ACHIEVE AND STILL MAINTAIN
POWER AND IT WAS GETTING HARDER
TO ACHIEVE NOW THAT'S WHAT
STAFF TOLD ME AT THAT TIME AND
BASED ON THE RESPONSE THAT YOU
JUST GAVE THE SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER. YOU STILL HAVE THE SAME
CONCERNS. AND IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
MAJOR POWER PLANTS COMING
OFFLINE ONE OF THOSE PLANTS
PRODUCES ABOUT. 10% OF THE
STATE'S ENERGY AND TWENTY
PERCENT. OF ONE I'LL USE ENERGY
THAT PROVIDES POWER TO THE
STATE TO OUR RESIDENTS- I
UNDERSTAND FROM YOUR COMMENTS
AND JUST WANT TO CONFIRM THAT
IS STILL A CONCERN OF YOURS-
YOU KNOW RAMPING UP AND HAVING
AND AFFORDABLE POWER. AT NIGHT
BUT I ALSO WANT TO KNOW WHAT
YOUR THOUGHTS ARE. ABOUT
REPLACING THE ENERGY TO SOON
GOING TO BE COMING OFF LINE AND
COULD CREATE MORE OF A
BLACKOUTS OR BROWNOUTS REALLY
BROWN- BLACKOUT SITUATION THAT
WE HAVE CURRENTLY EXPERIENCED.
LAST FALL- LAST SUMMER. SO I
THINK. IT'S CERTAINLY A CONCERN
IN THE SENSE THAT WERE VERY
MUCH AWARE THAT WE'RE LOSING
SIGNIFICAN AMOUNTS GENERATION.
IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS- AND WE
NEED TO START PLANNING.
ABSOLUTELY TODAY. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE REPLACE THAT WITH
RESOURCES THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE. WHEN YOU NEED TO.
AND FIND AGAIN I THINK
FLEXIBILITY IS THE KEY RELATED
RESOURCES THAT CAN GO UP AND
DOWN- WHAT THOSE RESOURCES WILL
BE IS GOING TO BE A
CONVERSATION. BETWEEN THE AYE
SO IN THE CPC. CPC HAVE
ALTERNATE JURISDICTION OVER
THESE ISSUES. BUT YES WE'RE
VERY MUCH AWARE. AND AGAIN I
STATE MY OWN VIEW ON THIS IS
THAT EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS. IN
THE WORLD OF FINANCE THE
DIVERSE PORTFOLIO IS THE WAY TO
REDUCE RISK. AND THE SAME IS
TRUE AN ENERGY. THAT IS I MEAN
REALLY PUTTING ALL YOUR EGGS IN
ONE BASKET IS NEVER GONNA BE
THE SOLUTION WE'RE GONNA NEED.
EVERYTHING'S SHORT TERM STORAGE
LONG TERM STORAGE. DIFFERENT
KINDS OF RESOURCES OFFSHORE
WIND HYDROELECTRIC NOT HYDROGEN
CIRCLE OF SOME HYDRO I MEAN
IT'S JUST THEIR DESK BURDEN YOU
DON'T REQUIRE TO HAVE TO FOCUS.
ON THE ENTIRE GAMUT OF THINGS
WE COULD GET. THANK YOU. I
WOULD ONLY ADD ONE SMALL ITEM
THAT IS NOT ONLY THE
FLEXIBILITY ON THE PEAK AT THE
END OF THE DAY THAT WE HAVE TO
MEET THAT WE'RE ABSOLUTELY
FOCUSED ON IS ASHLAND SHIN AND
NEED THE VALUABLE RESOURCES IN
THE FOURTH FOLIOS. AND THE
TECHNOLOGIES TO ALLOW US TO
MEET BACKGROUND WHICH STORAGE
IS SPECIALLY LONG TERM UTILITY
SCALE STORAGE. BUT ALSO WE NEED
TO BE COGNIZANT THAT THERE WE
OPERATIONAL INDEPENDENT RIGHT
NOW AND YOU NEED TO BE
COGNIZANT OF THE FACT THAT A
FEW. LOCAL OUT MOSTLY DAYS-
THAT DO NOT ALLOW US TO HAVE
ENOUGH ENERGY TO CHARGE TH
BATTERIES MAKE CALLS ADDITIONAL
PROBLEMS. QUICKLY INVESTING IN
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS OFFSHORE
WIND WHICH ACTUALLY COMPLEMENTS
THE EVENING PEAK QUITE NICELY
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL FOR US. AND
ALSO MORE STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES
TO ALLOW US TO OPERATE FOR A
FEW DAYS. AFTER DANCE AROUND
I'M RELIABLE SOLAR RESOURCES
DIVERSIFICATION. ON AN
ACCELERATED SCHEDULE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SIR RAY THE L. THE
IF ANY HELLO WITH TO BE PHASED
OUT BEFORE WE ARE WITH A THE TO
START PICKING UP FOR THAT LOST
THAT EVERYONE IS AWARE THIS IS
AN ISSUE. THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED THE GOOD CAUSE
OPERATIONAL. DIFFICULTIES IF
IT'S TAKEN OFF LINE I HAVE I
HAD ALMOST THE APPROPRIATE
TECHNOLOGIES COMING ONLINE.
THANK YOU MA'AM I APPRECIATE
THAT RESPONSE VERY MUCH- I DO
HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION.
CURRENTLY THE AVERAGE
RESIDENTIAL- ELECTRICITY IN
THREE CALIFORNIA I- USE I ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE- HOW'S THE COW
I ESTá WORKING WITH THE C. P.
U. C. AND THE C. E. C. TO
ADDRESS THE HIGH ELECTRICITY
RATES THAT CALIFORNIANS PAY
TODAY. I DON'T TO TRICKLE. TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THAT. ARMENIANS
YES BOOK BURNINGS DO WE DO HAVE
A HIGHER RATE FOR ELECTRICITY
CALIFORNIANS PAY YOUR BILL AND
I WERE BILLS TAKEN ON AVERAGE
WITH THE NATIONAL I'M PRETTY
MUCH IN THE MIDDLE WE ARE NOT
THE HIGHEST BILLS THAT THAT
CUSTOMERS DO PAY TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE CAN INFLUENCE THE
RACHEL RAY FERRIS RASPY
TRANSMISSION ACCESS CHARGE THE
B. EYES SO CHARGERS. WE HAVE
ACTUALLY MAINTAIN NOT AN OPTION
I'M SURE IF YOU'RE THE CHAIR
ALL OF OUR FINANCE COMMITTEE
WILL BE ABLE TO TELL YOU WHAT
THAT IS WITH THE PRETTY STABLE
FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS AND ALSO
D. E. I AM HAS BROUGHT
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS DIRECTLY TO
CALIFORNIA OUR REPAIRS WITH
RESPECT TO THE ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN SAVINGS THAT
HAVE OCCURRED. TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE I. S. OKAY AND ONE
THAT RUSSIAN OF THE BILL THAT
IS ASSOCIATED WITH OUR SERVICES
WE EITHER HAVE TO HAPPEN RIGHT-
WE'VE BROUGHT IN ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
OPERATE MORE RELIABLY AND BRING
MORE BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIA AND
NOT ONLY ARE WE OPERATING THE
ENERGY IMBALANCE MARKET WE'RE
DON'T HAVE ALSO BECOME THE
RELIABILITY COORDINATOR FOR THE
LAST WHITE RIGHT- WE ARE VERY
PROUD OF HAVING TAKEN. DOT
INITIATIVE AS WELL AND THAT
WILL BRING ADDITIONAL POTENTIAL
BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE
COGNIZANT THAT OUR PEOPLE PAY A
BILL WITH STANDS THAT OUR
SERVICES ARE PART OF THE REACH
THAT THEY PAY AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE CAN WATCH THOSE AND
KEEP THEM LOW. WE DO EVERYTHING.
WHATEVER THINKS THAT IS THAT.
WE HAVE. DO WE HAVE THE I. DOES
NOT CAN THE MIX OF RESEARCH OF
THE IN CAL. BUT WE DO OPERATE
MARKET I MEAN THAT'S THE BOOK
UP OTHER THE RELIABLE WHICH IS
FIRST FOREMOST WE UP A MARKER
WHICH IS THE WE TO REESE BASED
ON LEAST COST POSSIBLE AND THAT
ALSO DEBT THAT'S IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTOR TO KEEPING BILLS
DOWN-AND IT AND IT'S JUST THAT
THAT'S- THAT IS THAT IS ONE OF
OUR CORE FUNCTIONS. KAMALA
AGAIN SECOND ONLY TO
RELIABILITY. THANK YOU BOTH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS. THERE'S THANK YOU
SENATOR GROVE I CENTER LAYERED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- HE I
REALLY APPRECIATED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH BOTH
CANDIDATES HERE AND THE
INTERESTING THING ABOUT IT WAS
IS IT'S RARE WHEN YOU HAVE
THESE MEETINGS THAT YOU WISH
YOU COULD KEEP GOING AND THAT
IS CLEARLY WHAT WAS HAPPENING
WITH IT AND I AND MANY OF THE
THINGS- YOU. YOU SATISFACTORILY
ANSWERED MY QUESTIONS BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET
SOME OF IT ON THE RECORD THAT
HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS OUT IN
THE OPEN AND I'D LIKE TO PICK
UP ON A COUPLE OF THINGS FROM
EACH OF THE ARE THE PREVIOUS.
AND ONE IS YOU MENTIONED
BATTERY STORAGE OR YOU
MENTIONED STORAGE BUT OUR OUR
AND IT'S GREAT BECAUSE IT IN MY
DISTRICT OF FOSSIL FUEL PLANT
IN MOSS LANDING HAS BEEN
CONVERTED TO TWO BIG BATTERY
STORAGE ENOUGH PROPOSED FOR THE
FORMER PLANT AND MORAL BAY AND-
OUR OF WHAT DO YOU THINK. ARE
ARE. ARE THE GAINS THAT WERE
ABOUT TO MAKE IN BATTERY
STORAGE BUT WHERE DOES THAT
JUST LEAVE US WHY DOES THAT.
MATTER THAT SLIM COMFORT GIVEN
THE OVERALL LOOK AT THE PICTURE
YOU'RE DESCRIBING. WHAT I'M
SORRY I'M NOT I'M NOT DOING A
VERY GOOD JOB OF FACILITATION
I'M JUST TOO WRAPPED UP IN THE
CONVERSATIO SO- GO RIGHT AHEAD
AND- EITHER CAN JUMP IN AT
EITHER POINT UNLESS THE MEMBER
I'D DIRECTS A QUESTION TO ONE
OF YOU SPECIFICALLY SO I'LL
JUST SORRY FOR THAT- BUT GO
RIGHT AHEAD
TO POINT OUT VERY QUICKLY THAT
IT MAY BE SLIM COMFORT.
ALTHOUGH IT WILL BE A
TREMENDOUS HELP AND HAVING THAT
ALMOST TWO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
OF BATTERY STORAGE WHICH IS
VERY FLEXIBLE AND CAN RAMP UP
QUICKLY. AND PROVIDES A PLACE
FOR HOURS OF POWER WHICH IS
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AND THIS.
IS A GREAT RESOURCE IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE FOR US TO DO A LOT
OF SHIFTING. WE'RE ALSO SEEING
BACKGROUND LAST BEFORE HOURS-
THREE TO FOUR HOURS EVERY
EVENING EVERY DAY WHICH IS
CURRENTLY AT FIFTEEN THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS. BY TWENTY THIRTY AS
WE TRANSITION TO MORE
RENEWABLES ON THE GRID. THAT
RAMP IS EXPECTED TO BE ABOUT
TWENTY THOUSAND MEGAWATTS SO WE
NEED MORE STORAGE WE NEED MORE
FLEXIBILITY WE NEED MORE
GENERATION THE CAN RAMP UP
QUICKLY. AND WE EVEN PEAK
DEMAND AND ALLOW US TO RUN
THROUGH THOSE FOUR HOURS. AND
AS WE DO CARBONIZED NEED TO BE
LOOKING AT MORE AND A VARIETY
OF RESOURCES YOU. SHOULD BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THAT. WELL AND
JUST TO FOLLOW UP QUICKLY. I
MEAN I'M OBVIOUSLY A LAY PERSON
BUT I KNOW THAT NIGHT IS LONGER
THAN THREE OR FOUR HOURS. SO
HOW HOW DOES THAT HANDLE IT
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE SOLAR FOR
THAT PERIOD OF TIME. WE HAVE.
YES KNOW. IT DOES- I THINK THIS
IS WHAT I MEANT ABOUT
DIVERSITY. IS THAT- BATTERY
STORE FOR BATTERY STORAGE.
HELPS WITH ONE IS. BUT IT
DOESN'T SOLVE THE- A- HOW DO WE-
THE LIGHTS ON AT NIGHT AND
THAT'S WHERE DIVERSITY TO FIRST
PORTFOLIO IS SO IMPORTANT. IS
FOR NOW WE ARE STILL. WILL HAVE
HIGH DRUG WE HAVE HYDRO WILL
HAVE A HYDRO. AND WATER
OBVIOUSLY RUNS THE NIGHT OR
DAY- AND WE'LL HAVE SOME WIND
BECAUSE THE WIND ALSO DOES NOT
ENTIRELY DEPENDENT ON THE SUN.
BUT WE WILL HAVE TO LOOK AT
OTHER RESOURCE- AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT. THIS
INCLUDING ONE OF THE THINGS WE
NEED TO LOOK AT SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER IS MORE LONG TERM
UTILITY SCALE STORAGE- BECAUSE
THAT IS. SOMETHING THAT REALLY
ESPECIALLY IF COUPLED WITH
OTHERS WITH CLEAN POWER TO
CHARGE. IS ANOTHER RESOURCE
THAT WE CAN USE BUT IT'S NOT
IT'S NO SINGLE THING THAT'S ALL
OF THE ABOVE- FOR EXAMPLE
BATTERIES ALSO CANNOT SOLVE THE
PROBLEM OF WHAT HAPPENS IF IT'S
CLOUDY FOR FIVE. I'M THAT'S NOT
YET WHAT HAPPENS EVEN IN
CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE CLOUDY
WEATHER. AND OBVIOUSLY A FOUR
HOUR BATTERY IS NOT A REALLY IS
NOT THE SOLUTION TO THAT
PARTICULAR CHALLENGE. AND THEN
LET ME FOLLOW UP ON A QUESTION
THAT SENATOR GROVE PASSED IT
AND THAT'S THAT HE TALKED ABOUT
THE POWER PLANTS GOING OFFLINE
AND ONE OF THE BIG ONES IN MY
DISTRICT ABLOH CANYON AND WHEN
I TOURED THAT PLANT. ONE OF THE
FASCINATING THINGS I LEARNED AS
ONCE IT RAMPS UP IT RAMPS UP AT
THAT LEVEL FOR SEVEN DAYS THEY
THEY THEY CAN'T CHANGE IT AND
THERE WERE TIMES THAT
RENEWABLES WERE BEING REJECTED
ON THE GRID. BECAUSE YOU JUST
HAD THIS POWER COMING AT A NON
REGULATED LEVEL OUT OF TO HAVE
LOW CANYON. AND YOU'RE EXACTLY
THE AND I MEANT TO ASK YOU THIS
THE OTHER DAY YOUR THE ONES
THAT. WHERE THE RUBBER MEETS
THE ROAD ON REGULATING THE
POWER HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH THAT
WHEN THAT HAPPENS. WELL FOR NOW
DO. CANYON YES YES TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN AND IT'S BASED LOW POWER
BUT WE DON'T NEED AS MUCH
BASEBALL'S POWER IT'S SYSTEM
POWER WE DON'T NEED IT IS NOT A
CONSTRAINED EVERY YEAR FOR
LIABILITY THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT
AS CRITICAL. BUT ALSO IT'S NOT
FLEXIBLE AS YOU SAID IT IS A
VERY INFLEXIBLE RESOURCE THAT
WHEN YOU RAMP IT UP WE WRAP IT
DOWN IT STAYS THERE FOR DAYS.
AND WE NEED THAT FLEXIBILITY TO
BE ABLE TO RENT AND REGGIE UP
AND DOWN. THE FOUR HOURS ARE
IMPORTANT AT THE END OF THE DAY
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW LONG THE
PEAK LAST AFTER NINE PM- HOW
YOU STARTS TO GRADUALLY GO DOWN
AND IT'S PRETTY LEVEL TOWARDS
THAT THE WHOLE EVENING HOURS.
SO PROVIDING BASELOAD ENERGY.
TO THE EXTENT THAT IT CAN BE
CARBON FREE IS OF COURSE
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED. TO BE
FLEXIBLE BECAUSE WHEN THREE NEW
BOWLS WE KNOW THAT WE CAN
OPERATE A RELIABLE BRENT. IN
FACT IN CALIFORNIA RECEIVE
HOURS OF OPERATION IN CERTAIN
DAYS OVER 90% OF OUR COUNTRY
AND REGENERATE NOBLES. AND WE
KNOW THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN
RELIABILITY DIS IDEAL
CONDITIONS. THE NAME OF THE
GAME THOUGH YES MAINTAINED THAT
RELIABILITY WITH LOW CARBON
TECHNOLOGIES. EVERY SINGLE DAY
EVERY SINGLE HOUR AND SPECIALLY
TOWARDS. EVENING PEAK SO. I'M
DIVERSE CITY WORKERS LIABLE. IN
TURN OF HAVING TECHNOLOGIES AND-
TECHNOLOGY YOUR PARTICULARS
POINT OUT THANK LEAD US LONG.
THREE OR FOUR DAYS. ALMOST ALL
LEARNED SO- AND OPERATE THE
GRAY. IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR US
IN CERTAINLY FOLKS ON IT. AND
IF YOU. IF YOU HAVE OFFSHORE
WIND A RADICALLY IN THE SAME
REGION- AND YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT HOW THAT CAN BALANCE
THINGS OUT. HOW DOES THAT ET
INTO THE GRID ASIDE FROM WHAT I
MEAN DO YOU HAVE TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT THE ENERGY COMMISSION IN
THE CITING. A HOW DO YOU DECIDE
HOW TO ADD THAT INTO THE SYSTEM
IN THE RIGHT WHY. TO DO IT.
DON'T YOU JUST I'M SORRY. OKAY
JOINT TO SEARCH BECAUSE THE
OTHER COMMISSION AS A INSIDE.
THE CPC ADAM IN PRETTY. BUT WE-
DECIDE WHAT TRANSMISSION PRAGUE
WE HAVE TO APPROVE NEW
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS. IF IN
FACT FOR EXAMPLE OFFSHORE WIND
BURKE A GOAL IN IN A SPOT WHERE
WE ALREADY HAVE. LOTS OF
TRANSMISSION MOST OBVIOUSLY A
JOB YEAH WHAT CANYON WE CAN
REUSE THAT TRANSMISSION THE
TRANSMISSION IT USED TO BE USED
TO BRING THE OUTLETS ENERGY TO
THE STATE CAN BE USED TO BRING
WET. THERE ARE OTHER LOCATIONS
THAT. WE WOULD NEED TO BUILD
NEW TRANSMISSION FOR ESPECIALLY
IN THE NORTH MARKET THERE WERE
THE HUMBOLDT ONE WHICH IS THE
OTHER OPPORTUNITY YOU'VE GOT TO
BUILD NEW TRANSMISSION. YES
BECAUSE THERE WE DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH BUILT ALREADY ESTABLISH
TRANSMISSION AND SO. AND OF
COURSE THERE ARE YOUR- ISSUES
GOING INTO OFFSHORE WIND ARE
BEYOND MY EXPERTISE. THINGS
LIKE GRAPHICALLY WHAT'S
POSSIBLE. ISSUES I GATHER THERE
ISSUES WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DEMAND SO IT'S A
MULTI LAYER PROBLEM PARKING
WHAT IS ABOUT WHAT THE WHAT THE
EXPENSE WOULD BE A BUILDING
TRANSMISSION. OR USING AN
EXISTING TRANSMISSION AT THAT
POINT I KNOW WILL BE FACING A
COUPLE LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS THIS
YEAR ON THE SUN. AND LASTLY LET
ME ASK THE LAKE QUESTIONED THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT I THINK.
SOME. PEOPLE THAT DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE AYE SO. TELL US
WHY. WE JUST HAPPENED IN TECH.
IN RELATION TO HOW THEY ARE NOT
CONNECTED TO THE GRID WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IN THE SAME WAY IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE WAY WE
ARE CONNECTED TO THE WESTERN
STATES. WELLYES THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION WE ARE WE AREN'T
AS AS I POINTED OUT WE DO HAVE
THE ENERGY IMBALANCE MARKET AND
WE ARE INTERCONNECTED TO OTHER
STATES. CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY
CEMENT IMPORTER OF OURS SO WE
USED TO IMPORTING EXPECTS
BOARDING ENERGY AND OPTIMIZING
THAT EXPORT. TAXES IS ISOLATED
BUT HAVE ALWAYS BEATEN IRELAND
IN AN OFF THEIR OWN THEY DO NOT
ALLOW POWER TO COME IN AND THEY
ALSO DO NOT EXPORT OUR- THERE
ARE SMALL AREAS OF TEXAS AND
THE PANHANDLE AND- ALSO WHERE
THEY ARE INTERCONNECTED CHIU
SURROUNDING BRANCH AND THOSE
AREAS ACTUALLY HAVE POWER
THROUGHOUT THE CRISIS. BUT I
THINK MOST IMPORTANTLY WHAT WE
SAW IN TEXAS WAS A SITUATION
WHERE ONE THEY DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH RESERVE MARGINS THEY
AREN'T REQUIRED TO DO THAT SO
THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY WAS NOT
THERE. I ALSO DID NOT FOLLOW
FEEDBACK INSTRUCTIONS WHICH
WERE WHICH WERE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO INSULATE THEIR EQUIPMENT SO
WE SAW A MASSIVE THING. CROSS
THE BOARD OF I'M JUST REACHING
FOR THE NATURAL GAS INSTRUMENTS
FREEZING FOR THE NUCLEAR
TECHNOLOGIES I DON'T KNOW IF
ALL ELSE FREEZING SO THEY
COULDN'T ACTUALLY USE THE CALL
AS EFFICIENTLY AS WELL. WE ALL
HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE WINDMILLS
THE WINDOWS IS ACTUALLY A MYTH
WINDOWS- OPERATE RELIABLY AND
VERY COLD TEMPERATURES THEY
OPERATED ARCTIC IN THE NORTHERN
ST THEY OPERATE IN ARE YOU
WELL. IN FACT IN IOWA
MIDAMERICAN ENERGY RUNS A 100%
THE WIND POWER AND THEY'RE ABLE
TO BALANCE THAT RESOURCES
BECAUSE THEY ARE PART OF THE
GREAT ARE NEEDED WESTERN MARKET
THE MY SHOP. SO TAXES ACTUALLY
HURT THEMSELVES BY NOT
PARTICIPATING IN AN INTEGRATED-
CAPABILITY OF BRINGING EMPOWER
AND ACTUALLY OPTIMIZING THEIR
OWN EXPORT. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY OF ALLOWING THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE TO FAIL AND NOT
BEEFING UP INSULATING AND
RATHER RISING RECOMMEND AS
NECESSARY. TO BE ABLE TO
OPEATE RELIABLY. THANK YOU ARE
YOU CAN SEE WHY I HAD CUTTING
OFF THE CA. WHEN I READING WITH
THEM A AND YOUR- SPEAKS. I'M
GOING TO BE PLEASE TO SERVE YOU
BOTH THANK YOU MAY CHAIR.
EARLIER THANK I CAN'T OF A MORE
INFO TOP OF TO. SO OF YOU KNOW
TYPICALLY I KNOW THAT WE MOVE A
LOT FASTER SOMETIMES BUT I
DON'T THINK THAT'S ALWAYS.
NECESSARY WE'RE HERE TO DO A
JOB AND I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS THOSE OF US THAT. YOU
KNOW I LOOK TO THE SENATORS WHO
SEEMINGLY HAVE MORE IN DEPTH
KNOWLEDGE OF THIS TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND FOR MY CONSTITUENTS.
SO I APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS. SENATOR BATES OUT
LAST BUT NOT LEAST I GAVE YOU A
REPRIEVE HAVE BEEN. BUT BUT ALL
HAVE NOT BEEN ASKING THAT IS
THE SAME WAY WHO MADE THAT
STATEMENT ANYWAY. RIGHT GO
AHEAD SENATOR BABYFACE THANK
YOU TO BOTH OF YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE FUND WHAT IS A VERY
VERY COMPLEX FONG. AGENCY AN
ASSIGNMENT- I THINK FROM THE
CONVERSATION I JUST HAD ENERGY
WHEN A ONE BECAUSE- I LIKE THE
CONSTITUENTS WHO DON'T TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND I ALSO THE GREED AND
ALL OF THAT BUT WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF US STUDY OVER THE LAST
FEW DAYS HOUSE THIS.
APPOINTMENT PROCEDURE CAME
FORWARD. MY CONCERN IS THAT I
THINK THAT OUR ENERGY- PLANNING
IS REALLY HAMPERED BY THIS
RATHER INTRICATE AND EXPANSIVE
BUREAUCRACY THAT OVERSEES IT
TRYING TO FIND ACCOUNTABILITY.
I TRYING TO FIND GOALS
DELIVERABLES VERY DIFFICULT
WHEN YOU HAVE EACH AGENCY WAS
SOMETHING DIFFERENT I SERVED ON
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER'S. WE
COMMITTEE HE WANT TO BLOW UP
THE BOXES BECAUSE HE FELT THERE
WAS TOO MUCH STYLING THAT WENT
ON THROUGHOUT OUR GOVERNMENT
AND I THINK THE ENERGY
SITUATION HERE REALLY IS A
PRIME EXAMPLE OF WHY THINGS.
KIND OF GO AWRY OF MY CONCERN
LET ME I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS
ACTUALLY- THAT DEAL WITH. THE
OVERSIGHT NUMBER ONE YOU FALL
ON THE RELIABILITY ISSUE I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
THE LEGISLATURE TO BE DIALED
MORE INTO THEIR FUND IT WOULD
SEEM THAT THE CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN I ALSO. IN P. YOU SEE
IS WHERE IT BEGINS AND ENDS IN
TERMS OF THE RELIABILITY AND
WHAT IS AVAILABLE WHEN WE HIT
THOSE PIZZA ESPECIALLY IN THE
SUMMER. SO I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THAT WE GET SOMETHING DIRECTLY
FROM ISEL IN TERMS OF WHAT ARE
THE NEEDS IN TERMS OF THE AREAS
YOU SAID WE NEED MORE STORAGE
WE MEAN NEED MORE DIVERSITY.
AND WE NEED MORE COORDINATION
AND OVERSIGHT AMONGST ALL OF
THE AGENCIES ARE INVOLVED- YOU
KNOW ENSURING THAT OUR-
CONSTITUENTS HAVE THE ENERGY
THAT THEY NEED TO- THE POWER
THAT THEY NEED TO- FOR THEIR
LIVES OUT THERE. ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM SO THAT'S THE
DELIVERABLE I'D LIKE TO SEE US
RECEIVE OF MADAME POOLE TOWN A
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE ONE OF
THE- THINGS THAT CAME OUT YOU
KNOW SO THERE WAS A REVIEW BY
THE ISO CEO AND HE SAID HE HAD
WARNED THE PC FOR YEARS ABOUT
THE ENACT INADEQUATE. POWER
SUPPLY PLANNING DURING THE NET
PEAK IN SUMMER THAT COULD LEAD
TO POWER OUTAGES YET THAT KIND
OF ESCAPE TO HOLD OFF UNTIL
THAT HE HAD TO- THIS LAST
SUMMER. O I THINK THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. NUMBER.
TWO WE ARE TO MOVE TO. THE
ELECT VEHICLE MANDATE BY
TWENTY. I JUST USING THE
FIGURES THAT CAME OUT FROM THE
ENERGY COMMISSION OF THE STATE
NEEDS OVER ONE POINT THREE
MILLIONMORE CHARGERS. AT A
POTENTIAL COST OF THREE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS. THAT'S
JUST THE INFRASTRUCTURE DOES
NOT COVER THE COST TO UPGRADE
THE GRID. TO HANDLE ALL THOSE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. SO I'D LIKE
TO KNOW IF CAL AYE SO HAS DONE
ANY SORT OF STUY TO DETERMINE
WHAT THE GRID INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS ARE GOING TO BE. AND IT
WHAT IT WILL COST TO MEET ABOUT
TWENTY THIRTY ELECTRICAL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE GOAL.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
OUT YOU KNOW BACK TO THE
RELIABILITY OF THE GRID AND HOW
WE GET ALL THAT TO ADDITIONAL.
A POWER- TO RUN THE STATE IS
CERTAINLY TO BE AVAILABLE AT
THESE CHARGING STATIONS. TO
KEEP OUR STATE MOVING. SO I'LL
TOSS THAT TO YOU AND SEE IF YOU
CAN SHARE IN IN RIGHT NOW SIGN.
HOW WE WILL MEET THAT GOAL.
ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
NEEDED BOTH ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THE
PROVISION OF THE LAW THE POWER
THAT'S NEEDED. FOR A HUGE STATE
THAT STILL COMMUTES MAINLY. OF
I. R. TWO. SO HE SAID HE THANK
SENATOR- ABOUT WHAT YOU START
AND- AND THEN WE'LL GO. BACK TO
MR BACK. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR AND YES WE'LL BE HAPPY
TO PROVIDE A REPORT ON HOW WE
CAN BETTER COORDINATE TOGETHER
AND ACROSS THE BOARD AND ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WE HAVE MADE. IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE ISSUES
ARE. WORKING FROM THE SAME
PLAYBOOK AND ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES IN A CONSISTENT MANNER
ACROSS THE BOARD AND ACROSS
AGENCIES AND WORKING IN
COLLABORATION. WITH RESPECT TO
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLES WE ALWAYS
LOOK AT ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE IN ORDER TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
43% OF ALL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA A
VEHICLE AND MOBILE SOURCE
RELATED. WHICH MEANS WE NEED TO
BE WORKING EVEN MORE CLOSELY
WITH THE CC BECAUSE THEY'RE IN
CHARGE OF ELECTRIC VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD WHICH IS IN
CHARGE OF MOBILE RESOURCE. I'M
THE MANDATE FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES IS VERY EXCITING AND
IT CAN. BE A HUGE HELP TO. OR
CAN HURT DEPENDING ON HOW AND
THOSE VEHICLES STRONG. SO WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT AS WE ROLL
OUT THE LUXURY VEHICLES WE ARE
COGNIZANT OF THE FACT. THAT IF
ALL THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE START
CHARGING AT THE END OF THE DAY
WHEN WE'VE GOT THAT EVENING
BROWN- THEY MAY ACTUALLY HURT
THE GRANT SO THE EXTENT THAT WE
CAN INSULATE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM THAT
HAPPENING. AND STANDS
SUBSTANTIAL MONETARY STATIONS
SIGNALS ON MONETARY SIGNALS TO
CUSTOMERS NOT TO CHARGE DURING
THOSE PERIODS THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL. WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT MEDIUM AND LARGE
SCALE JUDY VEHICLES. AS WE
CONTINUE TO DECARBONISE THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS
ACTUALLY BEING ABLE TO HELP THE
GRANT AND HELP COMMUNITIES WITH
THE FINDER ACTUAL CHARGING. SO
DURING PEAK TIME WE WILL BE
ABLE TO DRAW POWER FROM THE
BATTERIES IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
THE GRANT. AND ALL THESE
VEHICLES DISTRIBUTOR THROUGH
ALL CALIFORNIA WILL ACTUALLY
INCREASE HOW THE CAPABILITY TO
INCREASE BRAND RELIABILITY IF
THEY'RE ACTUALLY OPERATED RIGHT
AND IF WE MANAGE TO ENSURE.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE- DISTURBANCE
AT THE END OF THE DAY OR WHEN
WE'VE GOT PEAK OF CONSTRAINT
GREAT CONDITIONS. AND WE WOULD
RATHER NOT HAVE THOSE VEHICLES
CHARGING AT THAT TIME BUT WOULD
RATHER BE PULLING ENERGY FROM
THEM. AND BECAUSE VEHICLES ARE
PRETTY MUCH PAR 480% OF THE
TIME WE DO HAVE THAT BY
DIRECTIONAL CHARGING
CAPABILITY. IT ACTUALLY CAN
HELP THE GRANT AND HAVING AN
EXCESS AMOUNT OF ENERGY ON THE
GROUND WITH RESPECT TO MORE
SOLAR AND RENEWABLES. BUT WE
SOMETIMES CARTEL DURING THE
TIME OF DAY BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO ACT TO
STRENGTHEN. CHARGING THOSE
VEHICLES AND CHARGING BATTERIES
EXTREMELY BENEFICIAL WE CAN
CERTAINLY LOOK AT- DESALINATION
PROJECT AS WELL AS STRINGS. AND
MOVING TOWARDS FUEL CELL
VEHICLES WHICH ALSO ELECTRIC IF
WE MAKE THE HYDROGEN WITH
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND BALANCE
THE EXCESS AMOUNT OF RENEWABLES.
THAT WAY AS WELL. BUT LAST
IMPORTANTLY DO NEED TO HAVE.
YOU PLACE CORD. THE HABITS- AND
CHARGING INTEREST TO BE CHARGED
NINETY NINE OR THE MIDDLE THANK
WELL WE'VE GOT ACCESS. AND IT
WON'T COST GRANT. SO BACK NICE
YOU'RE RIGHT. IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL AND WHEN HE WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE- WE ARE NOT
SURE OR- IN THE FOOT BY ATTRACT.
THE TRUMP. SECTOR BUT IN FACT
THEY'RE TAKING. OF THE
SYMBIOTIC OUR POTENTIAL OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES HELPING THE
GRANT AND HELPING GREAT
OPERATION ALLOWING. US TO
INTEGRATE MORE RENEWABLES. IT'S
WHAT I WANT TO GO I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING ACTUALLY SENT-
APOLOGIZE ADD TO THE IS.
TECHNOLOGY HAS IGNORE POTENTIAL
HERE- I'M HARD JOB HI SO IS TO
BUILD MARKETS. AND BUILD
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. TO PARTICIPATE AND FROM
FOR EXAMPLE THE IDEA OF BEING
ABLE TO OPERATE BATTERIES UP
AND DOWN BOTH HOME BATTERIES
AND ELECTRIC VEHICLE BATTERY SO
THAT THEIR PROVIDING POWER INTO
THE GRID. DURING OF TIMES WHEN
WE NEED IT AND THEN CHARGING
WHEN WE HAVE EXCESS POWER. THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS COMPLETELY
RETOOL- DISTRIBUTED RESOURCES
FOR INTEGRATING AMOUNT TO THE
GREAT HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PRIORITIES AT THE AYE
SO FOR THE LAST SIX YEARS. BUT
IT'S GOING TO BE SOMETHING THAT
WE PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
BUT IT'S THE PRIVATE SECTOR
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE TO STEP
IN. AND THEY'RE STARTING TO
PEOPLE LIKE TESLA ARE STARTING
TO STEP IN AND ACTUALLY BECAUSE
FOR THEM IT'S A MONEY MAKING
OPPORTUNITY IT'S NOT JUST THAT
OF. THEM I WOULD EXPECT I WOULD
BUSINESSES I WOULD EXPECT THEM
TO OPERATE FROM PROFIT. MOTIVE
OUR TRICK IS TO MAKE IT
PROFITABLE. I GUESS I SEE THAT.
pTHAT AN INDIVIDUAL FACES WHEN
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF A- HUGE
HEAT WAVE DO I'D CHARGE MY CAR
OR DO YOU LIVE. HE LEAVE THEIR
CONDITIONING ON. BECAUSE I
CAN'T SURVIVE THROUGH THE NIGHT
WITHOUT IT SO. THOSE ARE THOSE
ARE- HUGE ISSUES THAT REQUIRE A
TREMENDOUS EDUCATION. OF OUR
FOLKS OUT THERE. WHO THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE REALLY EASY WITH AN
ELECTRIC CAR JUST TO PLUG IT
INTO YOUR GARAGE ABOUT WHEN THE
ENTIRE POPULATION. WHO THE ****
ARE COMMUTERS IN THEIR OWN
AUTOMOBILES ARE TRYING TO DO
THE SAME THING- WE SURELY NEED
TO BE IN FRONT OF THAT YEARS
AND FRIEND OF TWENTY THIRTY.
AND I HAVEN'T HAD MUCH
CONVERSATION OR HEARD MUCH
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT. SO A
LOT OF CHALLENGES THAT YOU ALL
HAVE SERVING ON THE BOARD I
WILL BE VERY FRANK I TODAY I'M
NOT PREPARED. PREPARED TO
SUPPORT ARE YOU I NEED TO HAVE
MORE. REAL I NEED RELIABILITY
THAT YOU HAVE GOALS THAT YOU
HAVE DELIVERABLES THAT ARE
ALREADY PART OF WHAT IS BEING
PLANNED AND- TO BE PROVIDED TO
OUR LEGISLATURE BECAUSE THERE'S
A LOT OF TALK. ABOUT NEEDING
TECHNOLOGY THERE'S A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT. YOU KNOW WHAT'S
COMING THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TANGIBLE THAT I'VE
SEEN. AND I'M NOT SERVING ON
THE ENERGY COMMISSION-
COMMITTEE SO THERE MIGHT BE
SOME. THAT HAVEN'T BEEN ARE.
DISTRIBUTED TO THE DEGREE I
THINK IT'S VERY VERY NECESSARY
AT THIS POINT IN TIME. THAT I
COMMAND YOU YOU'VE BEEN BOTH
SERVING OUR EIGHT YEARS EACH
THAT'S NOT AN EASY ASSIGNMENT.
THAT WHEN THINGS GO WRONG LIKE
THEY DID IN TEXAS. ARE YOU WANT
TO MAKE SURE TAT YOUR
LEGISLATURE. I HAS BEEN FULLY
APPRISED OF WHAT'S BEEN GOING
ON AND YOU HAVE THE BACKING.
AND THE SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATURE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH INITIATIVES YOU FEEL. ARE
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURING THAT OUR PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDS WHAT'S COMING THEIR
WAY WHAT THEY NEED TO DO AND
ALSO THE COST. I UNDERSTAND THE
CHARGING STATIONS WILL BE A
COST OF THOSE WILL BE ADDED TO
OUR UTILITY BILLS ON OUR STATE
WHICH ARE. ALREADY VERY HIGH US
SENATE YOUR BROUGHT UP. SO A
LOT WORK. LAYS WITH YOU AND- I
AM CONFIDENT THAT YOU NEED BUT
I'M GOING TO KEEP THE CARROT
OUT THERE IN FRONT OF YOU AND
WOULD HOLD MY- SUPPORT TODAY.
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU KNOW
AND- IF ANY REPORTS OR OR ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE ACCESS
TO THAT. AND THEN YOUR
QUESTIONS ARE ANSWERED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR MISTER MAJORITY LEADER
YOU HAD ANOTHER COMMENTER
QUESTIONS TO FOLLOW UP WITH
JUST THAT ONE THING WAS
INTERESTING TO FOLLOW UP ON
CENTER BATES. YOU KNOW WITH THE
WITH THIS CAR CHARGING ISSUE
YOU CAN LITERALLY PUT ELECTRONS
INTO THE GRID FROM YOUR HOME
FROM YOUR FULL BATTERY IN YOUR
CAR IN THE MID DAY. AND GET
THREE TIMES AS MUCH MONEY AS
YOU GET PAID FOR CHART FOR PUT
PAYING INTO THE GRID. AND THEN
THE COMPUTER CAN TURN ON AT
NIGHT WHEN THE COST IS LOW. AND
THEN RECHARGE YOUR CAR SO YOU
BASICALLY PROVIDING ELECTRONS
AT THE PEAK POWER LIKE WE HAVE
PETERS. AT AT A MUCH HIGHER
RATE YOU CAN ACTUALLY BE AN
INCENTIVE TO ACTUALLY OWN AN
ELECTRIC CAR IT I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA SEE THINGS LIKE THAT IN
THE FUTURE AS WE BEGIN TO
INNOVATE MORE MORE. ASSEMBLY
CREATIVE INCENTIVE MODELS THAT
COULD ULTIMATELY WILL
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE COST OF
YOUR VEHICLE. YOU KNOW I JUST
WANT TO EAT IT IN THE INTEREST
OF LOOKING AT THE BIG PICTURE.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S SO DIFFERENT
NOW AS WE TRY TO MOVE TO GREEN
TECHNOLOGY. IF I HAD AN
AUTOMOBILE AND I NEED TO
TRAVEL. TWO HUNDRED MILES AND
MY CAR GOT. HIT TWENTY MILES TO
THE GALLON I WOULD PUT TEN
MILES OF TED TEN GALLONS OF
FUEL IN THE TANK. AND I WOULD
GO TO OUR MILES. NOW IS THE
GOVERNMENT WE'RE TRYING TO GO
TWO HUNDRED MILES. BUT WE DON'T
KNOW IF THE WIND'S GOING TO
BLOW WE DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
GOING TO BE CLOUD COVER. WE
DON'T KNOW IF THE EFFICIENCY OF
OUR TECHNOLOGY'S GOING TO DO A
DIG THE- DO GREAT BECAUSE OF
UP. THE HEAT. AND SO THE POINT
I WAS TRYING TO MAKE IN THE
BEGINNING IS WE HAVE TO REALLY
KIND OF BUILD REDUNDANCY IN
WHAT'S CALLED RESOURCE
ADEQUACY. WHICH I DON'T WHICH I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS YEAR
BUT WE HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH OF
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT IF THESE
UNFORESEEN EVENTS A CAR. RIGHT
FROM PROPER PLANNING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PUBLIC ITS STATE
DOESN'T HAVE BLACKOUTS AND
BROWNOUTS WE HAVE TO HAVE
ENOUGH REDUNDANCY IN THE
SYSTEM. SO THAT WE HAVE THIS
VOLATILITY THAT DOESN'T DOESN'T
CAUSE THAT PROBLEM AND THAT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY. THE ARCHITECTURE
OF THE PROBLEM FACING IN. ORDER
FOR OF THE SENATE AGREE YOU MAY
MEDICAL. ABOUT BATTERY OF THE
WAS A TWENTY. MEGAWATTS
WHATEVER YOU TALKED ABOUT.
FIFTEEN THOUSAND MEGAWATTS WITH
WHAT'S THE TIMING ON THAT
ANGELINA WHAT WHEN YOU THINK
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN TERMS
OF. WHAT WILL BE A FIFTEEN OVER
TWENTY BUT BUT ONE ONE'S A
HAPPENING WHAT'S OUR TIMING ON
THAT. IT'S HAPPENING NOW IN THE
GREAT EVERY DAY AND WE ARE ABLE
TO MEET THAT RAMP MOSTLY WHAT
IMPORTS AND SOME OF OUR GAS
RESOURCES RAMPING UP- DURING
THE EVENING PEAK. SO IT'S
HAPPENING NOW BUT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO WORDS TO CARBON
ISING IN DEEPER DECARBONIZATION
AND REPLACING THOSE RESOURCES
WITH CARBON FREE TECHNOLOGIES.
DELAY BATTERIES AS WE SAID LONG
TERM STORAGE OR GEOTHERMAL A
WIN OUR OTHER TECHNOLOGIES WE
CAN RAMP UP AND DOWN AND OF
COURSE. UTILIZING THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND THE BATTERIES
BEHIND THE METER AS WELL AS
EFFICIENCY WE NEED TO BE
COGNIZANT THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE MAD OR
IT HAS TO BE REDUCED- FOR ALL
OF US TO OPERATE THE GRID
RELIABLY. AND WE ARE VERY
FOCUSED ON ENSURING THAT THAT
HAPPENS. AND ALSO WITH RESPECT
TO ELECTRIC VEHICLES JUST TO
JUST TO POINT OUT THAT THE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO IS VERY-
BUT- WE HAVE CHARGING STATIONS
IN OUR HOMES RIGHT NOW EVERY
DAY. WHEN YOUR CAR INTO TO
TWENTY OUTLET IN YOUR GARAGE
RIGHT NOW. SO THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE ADDITIONAL CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS MOSTLY FOR
MEDIUM AND LARGE SCALE VEHICLES
AND OF COURSE LONG DISTANCE IF
PEOPLE WERE TRAVELING. AND IT'S
THE FAST CHARGERS THAT ZAP THE
SUSPECT THAT WE NEED TO BE
FOCUSED ON. BUT THOSE AREN'T
GOING TO BE AS MANY AS THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES THAT WILL
PROBABLY BE CHARGING IN THE
HOMES AND GARAGES PEOPLE MOST
OF THE TIME. WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
HAPPENS DURING THE NIGHT TIME
AS YOU POINTED OUT SENATOR
HERTZBERG. WHEN YOU CAN
ACTUALLY PLAY ARBITRAGE WITH
THE MARKET AND YOU'LL BE
SUPPLYING ENERGY TO THE GRAND
IF YOUR CAR IS PARKED IN YOUR
GARAGE WHICH WORKPLACE YOU'RE
NOT USING IT. DURING THAT PEAK
IN THE RAMP AND THEN CHARGING
IN THE EVENING OR DURING THE
MIDDLE OF THE DAY WHEN WE HAVE
EXCESS ENERGY. THANK WE ARE
HOPEFULLY NOT HAVING TO CURTAIL
BECAUSE WE'RE CHARGING. YOUR
CAR. THANKS YEAH I JUST AND
HAVE TO CLICK TO ADD TO THAT
ONE THING THAT THE REASON WHY I
TO RESERVE GOING AND LIKE NOW
IS INTEREST TO AUGUST OKAY SO
IN THE CITY WORK TOGETHER
REALIZE WE NEED TO FIFTY NINE
TO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF
RESOURCE IN THE GROUND NOW IN
BATTERIES ARE THE FAST TECHNO
TO BE TO WE CAN'T BUILD PLANT
IN SIX MONTHS BUT WE CAN
ABSOLUTELY DEPLOY BATTERIES SO
THE CPSC APPROVE NEW BATTERIES
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE BEING
INTERCONNECTED TO CRY SO GREAT
AS WE SPEAK. I JUST WANT TO
MAKE A POINT ON THE BATTERY
SHOULD KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT
YOU KNOW I'M GETTING CONCERNED
ABOUT THE NATURE THE BATTERIES
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT YOU'RE
DOING YOU'RE DOING A LITTLE BIT
IS SANK MOST OF STUFF YOU'RE
DOING IS LITHIUM ION READ THE
STORIES IN THE SIMPLE THINGS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND
THOUGH SO MANY COMPUTERS THAT
WERE BLOWN UP BECAUSE THEY GOT
TOO HOT THOSE HAD LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES SO HE NOT ONLY HAS A
DEGRADATION ISSUE ON THE SOLAR
SIDE. THERE'S ALSO RISK IN
TERMS OF THE BATTERY SIDE THE
IN THERE'S A NUMBER OF OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES FOR NOT USING
BECAUSE LITHIUM IONS THE STUFF
NOW BUT AGAIN LOOKING AT THE
RISK PROFILE LOOKING AT
RESOURCE ADEQUACY AND LOOKING
AT THE NATURE OF THE TOOLS WERE
USING IN THAT REGARD I JUST
THINK THAT YOU KNOW YOU NEED TO
BE SENSITIVE TO THAT BECAUSE I
IT IS NOT RISK FREE AT ALL
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF HEAT. THE
EXPLOSIONS ON THE BATTERIES A
SCENE BECAUSE OF THAT SO I JUST
AGAIN EITHER I DON'T WANT TO
STRESS IT BUT I JUSTWANT TO
PUT ON THE RECORD BECAUSE WE
GET AS WE LOOK AT ALL THESE
FACTORS WE HAVE VERY VERY
MINDFUL VERY CONSERVATIVE ABOUT
HOW. WE TRANSITION INTO THE
GREEN SPACE. I'M ABSOLUTELY
COULD. IF I MAY YOU. FOR OUT
OVER FOCUS ON THE RIGHT. WHAT
THE PRINTER. RISK BE WITH ALL.
ACROSS THE BOARD. WITH A BAD.
SPEED SO AND SOME OF THE
DECORATIVE. OF THE SOLAR. TIME
WHICH IS ABOUT 10% INCLUDING IN
THE HEAT AND AFTER TEN YEARS.
BUT ALSO WITH REGARDS TO GAS
POWER PLANTS WHICH WE HAVE
SEEN- ALSO OPERATE AND THEIR
EFFICIENCY DECREASED IN REALLY
HOT WEATHER. THE TUNE OF 20%
AND HIGHER WHICH HAPPENED THIS
SUMMER AS WELL. SUNDAY
GRADATION. AND REDUNDANCIES IS
ALWAYS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
MISTER DOC WILL LOOK BACK AND
WE NEED TO ENSURE WE HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCE. ENOUGH OF A
VARIETY OF RESOURCES. TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN ACCOUNT FOR ALL OF
THAT HAPPENING ESPECIALLY. THAT
THAT EVENING. THANK YOU AKAU.
THE WELL LET ME JUST- COMMENT
BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
I THINK- THIS BEEN A GREAT
DISCUSSION I THINK THE
QUESTIONS IN THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES. AGAIN I AGREE WITH
SENATOR BATES IT'S ALWAYS GOOD
TO GO. LAST OR NEAR LAST
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT ARE TOP OF THE MIND. I
HAVE ALREADY BEEN COVERED. SO
YOU KNOW FOR ME IT YOUR
EXPERTISE IS CLEARLY VISIBLE
TODAY- OBVIOUSLY- YOU KNOW THIS
IS THE KIND OF EXPERTISE WE
NEED I GET THAT THIS IS NOT
YOUR DIRECT DAY JOBS ALTHOUGH.
SOME OF WHAT YOU DO IS RELATED
BUT- IS A PRETTY SERIOUS ISSUE
IN A VERY SERIOUS JOB- FOR THIS
TO BE KIND OF YOUR EXTRA
CURRICULAR ACTIVITY. SO I
THINK- I THINK CALIFORNIA'S
CLEARLY FORTUNATE TO HAVE THIS
KIND OF OUR- EXPERTISE IN YOUR
TALENT SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT- THE OB I DON'T REALLY
HAVE A QUESTION- BECAUSE- IN
SOME RESPECTS I DON'T WANT TO.
BEAT A DEAD HORSE HARM. OR
ANYTHING- TO DEATH- BUT I DO
WANT TO SAY YOU KNOW I AGREE
THAT MARKETS ARE FINE AND GOOD
THINGS FOR SOMETHINGS. ARE
CLEARLY ARE MARKET FORCES ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
ECONOMY AND HOW THINGS WORK.
BUT I ALSO THINK WE'RE DEALING
WITH PUBLIC INTEREST IN THE
URGENT NEED FOR POWER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS IT'S MORE OF A
NECESSITY AS OPPOSED TO. ODD TO
THE OTHER SO I WANT TO POINT
THAT OUT AND THEN. BACK TO THE
HORSE. I YOU KNOW GOVERNANCE IS
IMPORTANT AND EVERY TIME A
APPOINTEES COME BEFORE US FROM
CAL AYE SO WE TALK ABOUT THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE. AND THE
FACT THAT WE AS LEGISLATORS GET
HELD ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THINGS GO
WRONG. AND YET WE DON'T ALWAYS
YEAH YES. IS A LOOK AT OUR
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY-
YEAH BACK BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETY NINE TWO THOUSAND- I
THINK I WANT TO SAY THAT THIS
IS THE ONLY DIRECT ABILITY WE
HAVE. TO HAVE SOME INPUT IN
THAT HAS THE LARGEST STATE
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE AND SO- I
JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT
AGAIN I KNOW YOU'VE HEARD IT
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN THIS
IS NOT YOUR FIRST RODEO TO
STICK WITH THE HORSE METAPHOR.
I IN TERMS OF BEING BEFORE
DIFFERENT RULES COMMITTEES SO I
JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT
AND APPRECIATE YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE FACT THAT
WE DO TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY. ARE
SOME OF US DON'T EXACTLY HAVE
YOUR LEVEL OF EXPERTISE
OBVIOUSLY SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
KNOW THIS ISSUE ENOUGH TO ASK
INTELLIGENT QUESTIONS. BUT I
APPRECIATE I YOU KNOW EVERY
THING THAT YOU SAID TODAY THAT
YOU'VE GIVEN US A FORWARD LOOK
AT WHAT YOU'RE STILL DEALING
WITH AND THE FACT THAT YOU TAKE
TIME TO HAVE A DIALOGUE WITH US
I REALLY APPRECIATE. SO I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THOSE COMMENTS
AND SAY THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING
THE QUESTIONS AND NOW WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
AND SO- I'M GONNA START. RIGHT
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE AND- SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
I ACTUALLY DO NOT SEE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE. AND I WOULD
ASSUME THAT MEANS THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE BUT I'M
GOING TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
ROOM ON MY VIRTUAL SCREEN HERE.
I SEE NO ONE APPROACH IN THE
PODIUM IN OUR ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SO I'M GOING TO TURN TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE. AND ASK OUR
MODERATOR WHO'S BEEN STANDING
BY PATIENTLY TO INTRODUCE HIM
OR HERSELF. AND DOES SAY
WELCOME. MODERATOR ARE YOU
THERE. I AM MADAM BROUGHT THEM
THIS IS NICK WITH EIGHTEEN T.
THANK YOU WELL WELCOME WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE YOU JOIN US TODAY
SO I WANT TO ASK IF YOU WILL
SEE IF THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAITING IN THE QUEUE
THAT YOU QUEUE UP ACTUALLY- TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF OUR-
APPOINTEES. BEFORE US TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
TODAY'S AMPLE- APPOINTEES.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. IT WILL BE
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. OKAY AND
AS WE'RE WAITING FOR PEOPLE TO
OUR QUEUE UP HOPEFULLY PEOPLE
ARE LISTENING OUT THERE I'M
GOING TO ASK OUR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO GIVE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY POSITION ON
THE APPOINTMENT AND AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF OUR STENOGRAPHER
SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. WE
WOULD APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
OUR FIRST. PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS FROM LINE
TWELVE LINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS I'M DANIEL
OF FOR NOW ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN CLEAN POWER
CALIFORNIA. THE AMERICAN CLEAN
POWER ASSOCIATION WORKS TO
CHAMPION POLICIES THAT WILL
TRANSFORM THE U. S. POWER GRID
TO A LOW COST RELIABLE AND
RENEWABLE POWER SYSTEM. AB P.
CALIFORNIA'S THE PROJECT OF THE
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION WITH
A FOCUS ON DRIVING MEDIA THINGS
DEVELOPMENT. OF NEW UTILITY
SCALE RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
STORAGE TO PROPEL CALIFORNIA
TOWARD A CARBON FREE ELECTRIC
FUTURE. WE WANT TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT CONFIRMATION OF BOTH
MESCAL HAVE THAT AS WELL AS THE
COST OF BY WHAT- METALLIC HAVE
UNDERSTANDS THE NEED FOR A
DIVERSE PORTFOLIO OF RENEWABLE
RESOURCES M. TORRANCE. THAT
MUST INCLUDE BOTH LAND BASED
AND OFFSHORE WIND MORSEL LEARN
MORE STORAGE DELIVERED OVER A
STATE AND MODERN TRANSMISSION
SYSTEM TO POWER CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. AND PROFESSOR BOB
WHAT'S EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE
WILL HELP HI SO THROUGH A
PERIOD OF INTENSE BUT NECESSARY
TRANSITION. TO HIGHER AMOUNT OF
CLEAN ENERGY ENSURING GRID
RELIABILITY AND ENABLING THEY
POLICY. IN A- MANNER. GREAT
HOPE FOR. THEIR APPOINTMENT AND
HELP YOU CONFIRM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF LINE
SIXTEEN SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEY JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF
OF HEALTH EPA AND HE EVEN
SUPPORTED METALLICA AND THEN
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THAT
CALIFORNIA'S VERSION FEE AND
DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL-
QUITE APPROPRIATE CLAIMANTS AND
THE SOUND OF A AND BOB WHAT AND
APPRECIATE- YOU BRING THEM CORD
IT CAN IT. THANKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES
IN Q. FOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR WILL
BE BACK WITH YOU IN A FEW
MOMENTS. OKAY I'M GOING TO TURN
BACK TO THE ROOM TO SEE IF
THERE ARE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. AND OF COURSE I
STILL SEE NO ONE- HERE AND- IN
THE AUDIENCE FROM THE PUBLIC
TODAY. SO WHEN I LOOK BACK AT
ROOM ONE TWELVE. AGAIN I SEE NO
ONE. HERE SO OFTEN MISTER
MODERATOR SOONER THAN EXPECTED
I'M BACK TO- TURN IT OVER TO
YOU FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
THE APPOINTEE ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
AGAIN THIS IS FOR OPPOSITION
AND THE COMMAND OF THE ONE
FOLLOWED BY THEIR GROW. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO LINES FROM
THE PUBLIC IN Q. WELL THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR LET ME THEN I'LL
BRING IT BACK INTO THE HEARING
ROOM AND ASK OUR- FURTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. YES MISS GROVE YOU
OBVIOUS I THINK HE WAS I THINK
HE WAS READY FOR THE MOTION GO
RIGHT AHEAD SENATOR GROWTH SO
JUST BRIEFLY I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR- THAT
OBVIOUSLY LIKE THE SENATE PRO
TEM SAID THE EXPERTISE THAT YOU
BRING TO THE ISO BOARD- I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR SOMEONE
WHO REPRESENTS AND SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF THE STATE'S- WHAT
YOU CALL CARBON A CARBON
ENERGY- I APPRECIATE YOUR-
WILLINGNESS AT LEAST THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU HAVE
THAT WE JUST CAN'T ARBITRARILY
JUST DISAPPEAR SMIS RELIABLE
YOU KNOW INEXPENSIVE RELIABLE
ENERGY FOR ENERGY THAT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE OR THAT IS NOT.
RELIABLE IN THAT YOU. HAVE THE
COMMON SENSE AND THE- THE
OBVIOUSLY EXPERTISE TO- MAKE
SURE THAT. AS WE MOVE INTO AS-
THE SYSTEM THE GREEN SYSTEM
THAT THE GOVERNOR IS TAKING THE
STATE. I DO APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT YOU ARE AT LEAST
REASONABLE ENOUGH AND
UNDERSTAND ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT
YOU CAN'T JUST ELIMINATE. A
RELIABLE SOURCES OF PATTER OF
POWER FOR AND RELIABLE SOURCES
OF POWER. IN MAKING SURE THAT-
CALIFORNIANS WILL STILL HAVE
AND ENERGY WHEN THEY NEED TO
FLIP THE LIGHT SWITCH ON SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR LET ME JUST
LET ME JUST I DON'T OFTEN DO
THIS BUT LET ME JUST MAKE SURE
AND ASK OUR- IF EITHER OF YOU
HAVE ANY CONCLUDING COMMENT YOU
WANT TO MAKE ANYTHING YOU. FEEL
COMPELLED TO SAY AFTER THIS
CONVERSATION. I KERETA HEAD
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN GO RIGHT AHEAD.
HEY SORRY HI YOU KNOW I JUST
REALIZE YOU'RE ACTUALLY THE
CHAIR SO THAT WOULD BE AN
APPROPRIATE THING TO SAY YES
THE SCALE OF IT TO GO RIGHT
AHEAD WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
I JUST WANTED TO STRESS THAT
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA NINE
SHOWS A TREMENDOUS ORGANIZATION
IT IS A HIGH FUNCTIONING
TECHNICAL ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO EXCELLENCE AND
THEN I LOOK FORWARD TO AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO- TO WORK WITH THE
AGENCY THAT IN THAT SENSE YES
THE BACKBONE. FOR DECARBONIZING
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD AND TO ENSURE THAT WE
DO THEIR LAST YEAR AND A
RESILIENT RELIABLE COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER WITHOUT
COMPROMISING RELIABILITY AND
SERVICE TO OUR CUSTOMERS AND WE
KEEP THE BILLS WELL AS WE
TRANSITION TO A CARBON FREE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR BUILDING
SECTOR INDUSTRY I'M ESPECIALLY
BASED ON THE CALIFORNIA ISO
PROVIDING CLEAN RELIABLE
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKINGWITH ALL OF
YOUR WHEN WE HAVE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT THE FACT. THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MORE
INTERACTION WITH US AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO HEAR TO PROVIDE
REPORTS INCLUDES MEETINGS
WHATEVER IS NECESSARY TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S DIALOGUE DANIEL
WELL APPRISED OF EVERYTHING
THAT WE HAVE THINKING ABOUT-
ARE FOCUSING ON AS WE BUILD THE
GRADE OF THE FUTURE SO THANK
YOU SCOTT HAVE A THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MR BACK WHAT. COM I WAS
OFF A GREEN WITH A RISK
ANGELINA SAID THE I IS A
IMPOSSIBLE AND- THERE UP TO THE
JOB I ALSO WANT TO AND I I'M
HERE THE CONCERN YOU'VE
EXPRESSED RELY I'M HIS THEM.
HAPPY BEFORE THE CONTINUE DO SO
IT IS TOP NUMBER ONE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ISO EVERYTHING
RELIABILITY IS THE FIRST ORDER
OF BUSINESS- AND WE HEAR I ALSO
WANT TO REITERATE SOMETHING
ANGELINA SAID AT THE END WHICH
IS AYE I REALLY DO HEAR YOUR
DESIRE TO HAVE MORE
COMMUNICATION FROM US AND BOTH
OF US I THINK CAN AGREE TO
COMMIT TO GO BACK TO THE STAFF
AND GO BACK TO THE BOARD AND
SEND THIS MESSAGE. CLEAR THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE MORE OPEN LINES
OF COMMUNICATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE SO THAT YOU'RE
AWARE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
THE GRADE WHAT THE NEEDS ARE
AND WHAT STEPS WE'RE TAKING AND
THAT'S. YOU HAVE MY PERSONAL.
THANK YOU VERY. MISTER LEADER.
I THINK YOU WERE I LIKE CAN I
MOVE BOTH WHICH TOGETHER-
SEPARATOR BOTH. YOU CAN MOVE
TOGETHER IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
WRITING AND GATHER. OKAY A
MOTION IS ON THE TABLE MADAM
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES. GROWTH I WROTE I
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG BY
LAYARD ARE VERY AYE BELIEVE
IT'S NOT LOADING IT'S NOT
VOTING ATKINS HI A CONCERT
FORTY ZERO FORTY ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU BOTH AND
THANK YOU BOTH. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. VERY MUCH WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK- ON BEHALF OF WELL WE'LL
TAKE A FIVE MINUTE BREAK WE'LL
BE BACK IN FIVE MINUTES.
TO THE
NEXT ITEM WHICH IS ITEM ONE
SEE. AND THAT'S THE APPOINTMENT
OF DANIEL SEIZING GOLLY MEMBER
THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL.
HI MISTER THINK OLLIE GOOD TO
SEE YOU WELCOME THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU CHAIR
I CANS SO I WILL INVITE YOU TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELF ACKNOWLEDGE
HER THANK ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS
AND I'LL COME RIGHT BACK TO THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. WELCOME
THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN SURE I
CAN SLICE YOUR BATES. MAJORITY
LEADER HERTZBERG SENATOR GROW.
SENATOR THEIR I'M- I DO HAVE
FIVE WITH ME MY PARTNER OF
FORTY YEARS TRUCK STOP WILL IS
NOT GONNA GET ON CAMERA BUT-
WE'RE CELEBRATING FORTY YEARS
IN JUST A FEW DAYS HERE AND OUR
ELDEST SON LINK IS ALSO IN THE
VICINITY HE'S ALSO BE I'M HEAD
OF OUR IT DEPARTMENT HERE IN
OUR HOME SO WHAT HAVE YOU
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WILL BE.
BAILING OUT. I WANT TO THANK.
YOU SENATORS AND YOUR STAFF
WILL BE GENEROUS WITH YOUR TIME
IN ADVANCE OF THIS HEARING.
PROBABLY GOOD DISCUSSIONS AND
NOT ADDRESS QUESTIONS. THAT I
HAD WITH SOME OF YOUR
INDIVIDUAL THEM WITH YOUR
TEAMS. I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR OF COURSE WERE GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
CONSIDERED. ARE YOU FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT- SOME OF YOU KNOW
EVOLUTION IS THE FOURTH
GOVERNOR. AND I WORKED FOR.
OVER THE YEARS REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS. I'M
STARTING IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. AND- I HAVE TO SAY
PREPARING FOR THIS HAS BEEN
INTERESTING FOR ME BECAUSE I
DISCOVERED THAT I STILL HAVE
THAT SENSE OF AWE THAT I HAD
WHEN I WAS A FELLOW IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND EXACTLY
FOR JERRY BROWN'S. IN WHICH ALL
OF ONE POINT. I NEVER LOST OUT
WALKING INTO THE- CAPITOL
BUILDING. AND THAT BEING MY
PLACE OF WORK. AND ABOUT HOW
MANY YEARS I WAS AT IT AND I
STILL FEEL THAT YOU CONSUMING
AND- RIGHT NOW. I'M AND THE
OTHER THING I HAVE I HOPE. YOU
ALL KNOW I CARRY WITH ME. HI
GOING ALL THE WAY BACK THEN.
THIS IS FROM MY FAMILY. AND
THAT IS A DEDICATION TO
SPEAKING UP FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
MOST VULNERABLE. AND FOR THE
VALUE OF THEIR LIVED EXPERIENCE
ALONGSIDE THE EXPERTISE. OF THE
EXPERTS AND INVEST. HI MY
RELATIVELY NEW TO THIS. COUNCIL
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF.
SCIENTIFIC EXPERTISE AND IT'S
AWESOME I'M LEARNING SO MUCH
AND IT'S SO IMPORTANT IN THIS.
THESE TIMES IN SITUATION RENT-
BUT SO IS THE LIVED EXPERIENCE
THE PEOPLE. WHO ARE MOST
AFFECTED BY IT AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING I. I WANT TO KNOW IS
KIND OF IN MY DNA- ON SURE
QUICKLY A FAMILY STORY THAT I
THINK. ILLUSTRATES WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT IT IS ALSO
RELEVANT TO THE DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL. MY
MATERNAL. GRANDFATHER MY MOM'S
DAD. HOW'S THE SMALL. YOU POOR
FARMER. ON THE DELTA STARTING
IN EIELSON AND ENDING. UP IN
WHAT IS NOW NORTHERN. NORTH
SACRAMENTO. HE GREW WALNUTS
BLACK WALNUTS INSOLVENCIES
CANDY- BACK THEN DURING THE
DEPRESSION AND SOME YEARS
AFTER. AND THERE WAS A STORY HE
TOLD- THAT WAS ABOUT WHEN THERE
WERE THE HEAVY RAINS AND THE
RISK OF FLIGHT. TO THEIR
FARMLAND AND HE STORY GOES AND
HIS NEIGHBORS. AND MY UNCLES
AND MY GRANDPA SENSE WOULD
PATROL THE LEVY BACK AND FORTH
IN THE RAIN. WITH SHOT GUNS
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVED- WITH
SOME REASON THAT IF THEY
WEREN'T THERE TO PROTECT THE
LEVY THAT THE MORE WELL HEELED
INTERESTS WOULD ARRANGE FOR
SOMEONE TO COME DOWN FROM THOSE
AREAS AND INTENTIONALLY FLOOD
BEFORE FARMS TO AVOID THAT
HAPPENING TO THE MORE AFFLUENT
AREAS OF SACRAMENTO. AND THAT
STORY IS AN EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING THAT STUCK WITH ME
ABOUT EQUITY. AND DEFENDING
THOSE WHO ARE AT A DISADVANTAGE
WHEN BIG DECISIONS ARE MADE
ABOUT THINGS LIKE THAT. THE
THREAT OF FLOODS IS STILL TOP
OF MIND FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES I'VE BEEN MAKING A
POINT OF LISTENING ALL I CAN'T.
TWO OF THOSE WHO COULD BE MOST
IMPACTED BY SOME OF THE
DECISIONS. YOU MAKE AND WE MAKE
THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL.
AND WHAT COMES UP MORE THAN
ANYTHING FROM MARVEL
COMMUNITIES ACTUALLY RISK OF
FLOODS. ABOUT A FIFTH OF DELTA
RESIDENTS ARE IN IMMINENT
DANGER OF FLOOD. A CONSEQUENCE
THE FUNDING OVER THE NEXT.
SEVERAL YEARS SO I WAS I WAS
LISTENING. TO YOU I MAJORITY
LEADER HERTZBERG TALKING ABOUT
ENERGY THE PREVIOUS HEARING
WHICH IS FASCINATING TO ME- BUT
EVERYTHING YOU SAID ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS ALSO RELEVANT
TO WATER AS YOU KNOW YOU WILL
NOW- AND SPEAKING AGAIN ABOUT-THOSE WHO. STAND TO BE MOST
IMPACTED BY THAT PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE A VEHICLE FLEET.
WHEN THERE'S A CRISIS LIKE A
FLOOD OR FIRE PEOPLE WHO WORK
OUTSIDE. WHEN THE HEAT IS
EXTREME. SO I WELL I. APPROACH
THIS. IS SO FAR I WILL GOING
FORWARD IN A BALANCED WAY. WHEN
IT COMES TO SOME OF THE MOST
CONTENTIOUS ISSUES AROUND
CONVEYANCING- AND OTHER THINGS
A COUPLE TALK ABOUT NOW. THERE
IS ONE THING I AM JEALOUS ABOUT
AND THAT IS HOW THESE ISSUES
AFFECT PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE HOW THE LEAST. VOICE
SOMETIMES REALLY APPRECIATED.
YOUR TIME. SURE I CAN TALK
ABOUT IMPORTANCE OF GOVERNANCE
AND PARTICIPATION IN COURT. YOU
KNOW THIS HEARINGS A PART OF
THAT THAT'S TERRIFIC. YES I
COUNCIL THAT I SET OUT TO ASK
QUESTIONS BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT
I DON'T KNOW ASKING QUESTIONS
IN PUBLIC FORUMS THAT THE
ORDINARY PEOPLE MIGHT ALSO ASK
AND SUPPORTING THEM WHEN THEY
DO WHEN THEY SHOW UP AND TRYING
TO MAKE SCIENCE MORE ACCESSIBLE.
IN A WAY THAT. WE CAN REALLY
HEAR FROM IN A MEANINGFUL WAY.
PEOPLE ARE THE MOST TO LOSE.
MOST AT RISK. IS SOMEBODY'S BIG
ISSUES THAT WE'RE GRAPPLING
WITH GROUND WATER CLIMATE
CHANGE CENTER. SO I'M GONNA
WRAP UP THEIR DISBURSING AGAIN
I'VE HAD A LONG. HISTORY AND
STATE SERVICE. I'M MY BROTHER
WHEN I TOLD YOU ABOUT THIS
CHAPTER SAID WELL MAYBE THIS IS
HER ONE LAST CHANCE TO GET IT
RIGHT AND SO IN THAT SPIRIT OF
HUMILITY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND WILLINGNESS
TO MAYBE GIVE ME ONE LAST
CHANCE TO GET IT RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ESTERS
AND GOLLY LET ME START IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION TODAY
SENATOR GROW YOU WANT TO KICK
US OFF. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU MR THEN GOLLY FOR
BEING HERE TODAY WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT I HAVE THREE
QUESTIONS IF WE COULD ANSWER
AND I'LL TRY TO GO QUICKLY. AND
WHAT KEY CRITERIA DO YOU
BELIEVE THE DSE SHOULD BE OR
SHOULD USE IN EVALUATING
WHETHER THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED DELTA CONVEYANCE
PROJECT IS CONSISTENT. WITH THE
DELTA PLAN- THE REASON WHY I
ASK THIS IS THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS WHETHER THE DELTA
CONVEYANCE PROJECT PUT IT TO
ACHIEVE. THE REGULATORY
APPROVALS NECESSARY TO PROCEED.
AND WHETHER STAT WATER PROJECT
EAT WATER USERS WOULD
ULTIMATELY AGREED TO PAY FOR
THE PROJECT IF IT IS APPROVED.
AND IN YOUR VIEW WHAT STEPS
WOULD- SHOULD WE STATE WE
SHOULD WE TAKE TO CONSIDER
MAKING TO APPROVE THE WATER
SUPPLY. REBUT LIABILITY IF THE
PROJECT DOES NOT MOVE FORWARD.
I THANK YOU CENTER GROVE THE
QUESTION. AB SO THE COUNCIL
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE TIME NOT
FOR LOOKING AT THE CONVEYANCE
PROPOSAL HAS IT COVERED ACTION
IN OF ITSELF BUT WITHIN THAT
PROPOSAL I'M WE WILL BE LOOKING
AT- THERE FOURTEEN REGULATIONS
I BELIEVE THAT- WILL BE PART OF
OUR REVIEW. THE ONES THAT
REALLY STOOD OUT FOR ME IN
PREPARING FOR THAT WITH THAT
COMES AS I'M DOING NOW- ONE
AGAIN AT TRIGGERING THE FOR ME
WERE TO IS AN ISSUE OF REAL
PORN STAR HOPE ALLOWED DOLLY AT
THE COUNCIL THAT'S LOCAL INPUT
IT THAT'S REQUIREMENTS. AND ONE
THEY YEAH THE COUNCIL HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO INSIST ON SO I'LL
BE KEEPING A VERY CLOSE EYE ON
THE OUTSIDE STERN AUTHENTIC WAY
COLLUSIVE WAY GET A PEOPLE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE WHOSE VOICES
SOMETIMES LET OUT A SHOUT- BUT
DEFINITELY THAT THE- IT'S
INFORMED BY SCIENCE. THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE AND- MY THING
I'M LEARNING IS THAT THERE'S
KIND OF SNAPSHOT SCIENCE WITH
THERE'S FOUR K. SIGN WHICH IS.
SITUATION LIKE THAT SO THEY
COULD BE IMPORTANT FOR ELEMENTS
THAT PROJECT TO BE. EVALUATED
BASED ON FORECAST SCIENCE-
ANOTHER ONE JUST THAT I SEE AS
IMPORTANT ALMOST TO YOU NOW WE
CAN WRITE THIS TO YOU BUT- IT
THOSE WHO BENEFIT FROM ANY
CONVEYANCE. PROJECT WILL
DEMONSTRATE YOUR REDUCE
RELIANCE ON DETAILS. BECAUSE
FOR US TO MAKE THIS ALL WORK
COMMITTEE. PIECE OF THE PUZZLE
ON THERE ARE FOLKS THERE IN
THAT ROOM NOW KNOW THIS BETTER
THAN I DO BUT- THAT'S AN
ESSENTIAL PART. TIME THE
COUNCIL SUPPORTS CONVEYANCE BUT
IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE HAVE TO
REDUCE RELIANCE. ON THE DELTA
MORE THAN HALF. OF CALIFORNIANS
TODAY. DEPEND ON DELTA WATER
FOR SOME OF THE SOME OF THEIR
DRINKING WATER- AND THAT'S
THAT'S A HEAVY LOAD. SO SO THAT
THOSE ARE THE CRITERIA THAT
REALLY JUMPED OUT AT ME IN
RESPONSE TO A QUESTION SENATOR.
BUT THAT THERE ARE FORTUNATE WE
WOULD YOU KNOW TAKE UNDER
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE DID BRING IT
JINKING WATER AND THAT WAS A
QUESTION THAT I HAD AS WELL.
YOU KNOW REPRESENTING THE BACK
OF THE VALLEY THE CENTRAL
VALLEY I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
YOUR THOUGHTS ARE ABOUT- HOW
DID YOU MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES NOT
SPECIFICALLY IN THE VALLEY BUT
FROM THE VALLEY AND BEYOND. AND
BALANCE THAT DRINKING WATER.
FROM THE DELTA IN THE INTEREST
IN THE DELTA SO. ARE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THE VALLEY AND BEYOND I'M
RECEIVE DRINKING WATER FROM THE
DELTA AND I'M JUST CURIOUS
ABOUT HOW. YOU'RE GOING TO
BALANCE THOSE NEEDS WITH THE
NEEDS- THAT THE. IN THE DELTA
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY HAVE. YES
SO I YOU TO- LANDED ON WHAT IS
ONE OF THE BOYS IMPORTANT
RESPONSE. OF THE COUNCIL ON IS
RELIABLE RELIABLE SOURCE OF
WATER. AGAIN I HAVE A HISTORY
OF. SOME INVOLVEMENT WITH THE
ISSUE OF ACCESS TO DRINKING
WATER FOR ME IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL
HUMAN RIGHT IT'S LIFE ITSELF AS
YOU KNOW- I WAS AMONG THOSE WHO
WAS STUNNED AND ASHAMED. WHEN
WE DISCOVERED A SHORT TIME AGO
THAT THEY WERE PERHAPS MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. WHO DID NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE HEALTHY DRINKING
WATER AFTER BATHING DRINKING
FOR COOKING AS YOU KNOW AB I
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE.
OF THOSE OF YOU IN THE ROOM
LEADERS IN THE ROOM RIGHT THERE
ARE FOR SHARING SHOCK AND-
DOING A LOT TO RECTIFY THAT I
THINK WE'RE ON TRACK TO
POTENTIALLY BEHIND US. BUT THAT
THAT'S ONE OF THE TWO PILLARS
OF WHAT WE SEE AS OUR OUR
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE COUNCIL
IS RELIABLE WATER THE OTHER IS
TO PROTECT AND RESTORE THE
DELTA AND WHAT I'VE TRIED TO DO
IS NOT. SEE THOSE IN IN
CONFLICT WITH EACH OTHER
NECESSARILY BECAUSE THE FACT IS
I'M LEARNING MORE EVERYDAY FROM
SCIENTISTS BUT- A HEALTHY
ECOSYSTEM. IS BETTER FOR
RELIABLE WATER. AND THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY AT ODDS BUT TO GO
TO GET TO THAT PLACE. I HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE TWO THINGS
DO NOT ALWAYS HAVE TO BE IN
CONTENTION MEANS WE HAVE TO
LISTEN TO EACH OTHER BETTER
BLAND'S SCIENCE I BE WILLING TO
COLLABORATE AND COMPROMISED SO
IT'S HOLDING THOSE TWO THINGS
IN BALANCE. AT THE SAME TIME
BUT I THINK THE PRIMARY FOCUS
YOU GET ON IT. THE COUNCIL AND
IN DOING SO RECOGNIZING THAT
THE DELTA IS ALSO A PLACE. AS
MY FAMILY HISTORY TELLS ME- AT
TIMES. THE PEOPLE LIVE THEY-
AND IT WOULD YOU HAVE TO BE
VERY. OF THE PEOPLE THERE AND
THERE LOOK THERE'S THEIR WITH.
ARE IMPORTANT AS WELL. THANK
YOU SIR I APPRECIATE YOUR HEART
COMMITMENT TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT WERE WITHOUT WATER AND
THAT COULD POSSIBLY BE WITHOUT
WATER IN THE FUTURE. THE LAST
QUESTION I HAVE IS IT DO YOU
SEE A NEED TO BETTER RECONCILE
THE TWO THOUSAND AND NINE.
DELTA REFORM ACT- WITH HOW IT'S
BEING IMPLEMENTED TODAY. I'M
NOT SURE THAT I WOULD THANK.
RECOMMEND THAT AT THIS MOMENT I
WILL SAY- CAN YOU HAVE BEEN
AROUND FOR A LONG TIME NOT IN
THIS DEEPER LEVEL OF WHAT YOU
WANT ISSUE AREA BUT- I WAS
AROUND ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT-
THERE WAS A TIME. WHEN WE WERE
MUCH LESS. WELL COORDINATED
THAT WE ARE NOW I REMEMBER
WHEN. EVEN WHEN I WAS IN HIGH
RANKING POSITIONS AND
ADMINISTRATIONS IT WAS HARD TO
JUST GET SIMPLE INFORMATION.
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY. A
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND
JURISDICTIONS. NOT REALLY
TALKING TO EACH OTHER VERY
WELL- RIGHT IN AND A GREAT DEAL
IN MY OPINION LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY IT'S HARD FOR ME
TO GET ANSWERS WHEN I COULD NOT
I WAS A HIGH RANKING POSITION
MATCH IF YOU'RE JUST A MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC RESIDENT
SOMETHING AT STAKE IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET A STRAIGHT
ANSWER CONSISTENT ANSWERS IT'S
CLEARLY A BETTER SITUATION NOW
IN TERMS OF COORDINATION-
TRANSPARENCY THAT DASHBOARD.
THAT ARE AGENCIES INVOLVED WITH
HAS MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE I
THINK IT'S JUST GETTING BASIC
INFORMATION WHETHER IT'S BROKEN
WATER USE OR HABITAT
INFORMATION FLOOD INFORMATION
SERVICE RECORD RECREATION
PRISON YOU GET ALL KINDS OF
INFORMATION ON DASHBOARD AND
THAT'S NEW SO I THINK IT'S
GETTING BETTER I'M NOT GOING
TO. TELL YOU ALL WHAT TO DO
TERMS OF- YEAH. GOING FURTHER
AT THIS MOMENT BUT- PROPERTY
I'LL BE ABLE TO THINK SMART.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY ASKS
US QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SENATOR.
I THANK YOU I'M GOING TO TURN
TO OUR FORMER SECRETARY AND
SENATOR LAYER TO SEE
INTERESTING QUESTIONS COMMENTS
HE MIGHT PUT BEFORE YOU MISTERS
AGO ALI. YEAH JUST IN CASE I
DIDN'T MAKE IT CLEAR I STILL
HAVE BEEN A LOT LIKE WHEN I WAS
A YOUNG FELLOW BUT I'M ALSO
TERRIFIED LIKE WHEN I WAS A
YOUNG FELLOW WHO. ON THEIR-
HE'S STILL JUST HE'S A
SWEETHEART AT YOU GO RIGHT
AHEAD SENATOR. I'LL DO THAT IN
PUBLIC NO THAT'S OKAY I COULD
SEE A MOVE HIS HAND TO HIS
WALLET SO I KNEW WHAT WAS.
HAPPENING THERE- AND I KNOW HIM
WELL I THINK HE'LL BE A OF A
GREAT. OF SERVANT HERE AN ODD
YOU KNOW AND I HAVE MY OWN
CHECKERED PAST I WORKED RIGHT
OUT OF COLLEGE FOR CONGRESSMAN
WALTER WHO HATED DELTA
CONVEYANCE AND WAS DEDICATED
AGAINST US AND THEN WORKED FOR
JERRY BROWN FOR EIGHT YEARS
WHO'S DEDICATED TO BUILDING IT
AND SO. YOU KNOW I WORK FOR
PEOPLE THAT HAVE FIRMLY BEEN ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE ISSUE THEN I
THINK THE DANIEL THE ONE THING
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT IT IT'S
A LITTLE. I TAKE OFF ON SENATOR.
QUESTION A AND IT'S BASICALLY
THAT. THAT THE DELTA REFORM ACT
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE. ARE YOU
TALKED ABOUT GOVERNMENT SHOULD
SET UP ALL THIS GOVERNMENTS. SO
YOU HAVE THE DELTA CONSERVANCY%
THAT'S DOING HABITAT
RESTORATION YOU HAVE- THE-
DELTA PROTECTION COMMISSION
THEN YOU HAVE THE- THE DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL THIS IS
JUST COMPLETELY SEPARATE FROM
EVERY STATE AND LOCAL AGENCY OR
FEDERAL AGENCY THAT DOES IT
TOO. SO THERE'S JUSTICE ANALYST
JURISDICTION THAT EVERYBODY HAS
ON THIS ISSUE. AND THE- THE
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL WAS CREATED
PRIMARILY TO REVIEW AGAINST
SCIENCE A CONVEYANCE- PROJECT
THE TWELVE YEARS LATER HAS
NEVER COME FORWARD TO THE- ODD
TO THE STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL. AND
SO THE QUESTION IS. WHAT'S THE
FUTURE OF THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL DO YOU THINK THIS IS A
AN AGENCY THAT IS NOW CREATED A
MISSION DO YOU THINK ONCE IT
REVIEWS A CONVEYANCE PROJECT IN
DEALS WITH THAT THAT IT IS
LIVED OUT ITS MISSION. WHAT DO
YOU THINK THE FUTURE OF THE
AGENCIES. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION- SOONER THAN LIKE TO
GIVE MORE THOUGHT TO I MEAN I
WILL SAY. FROM THIS VANTAGE
POINT AND THIS IS NEW FOR ME AS
YOU KNOW I. GENERALLY IS IT
PASSED FROM CITY. LANDSCAPE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS AND HOW THEY'RE
INTERACTING WITH EACH OTHER NOW
I'M LOOKING AT IT FROM. FROM
ONE PIECE OF THE PUZZLE. I WILL
SAY THAT- PERSONALLY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR JESSICA PERSON IS
OUTSTANDING. SHE SEEMS TO
UNDERSTAND. IT BETTER COR. SAID
GOOD GOVERNMENT IS NOT ABOUT
EXERTING YOUR AUTHORITY OR
POWER IS MORE ABOUT INFLUNCE.
AND THE DELTA COUNCIL DOESN'T
HAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
AUTHORITY OVER A LOT OF THINGS.
AND THAT CEO OF JURISDICTION
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS YOU
KNOW. BUT SHE AND HER TEAM SEEM
TO DO A VERY GOOD JOB OF
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS. SETTING
TABLES ARE SHARING INFORMATION.
AND NOT NOT JUST IN ONE
DIRECTION WHERE YOU GET
INFORMATION FROM ONE SURE WITH
ANOTHER- THEY REALLY SEEM TO
HAVE MASTERED. THANK YOU IT
TOOK ME YEARS TO GAIN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
GOVERNMENT. OF THE INFLUENCE
CAN BE BETTER THAN THAT FORTY
SO I THINK THAT IS DEFINITELY
AN ADDED VALUE- BUT I'M
COGNIZANT OF YOUR POINT THAT-
CONVEYANCE. IT'S KIND OF A
CENTERPIECE OF A LOT OF YEARS
YOU'RE SPEAKING AND
UNDERSTANDING OF. WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE AND- I GUESS TIME
WILL TELL. WHETHER AND BEYOND
THAT- NOT PLENTY TIME COME.
WE'LL STILL NEED TO. THE TALK
TO STORAGE ACCOUNT BUT I WILL
MY PRESS IS THAT THIS
PARTICULAR TEAM OF PEOPLE ARE
ADDING VALUE. TO A VERY COMPLEX
DIFFICULT. LANDSCAPE ONE OF
THEM LET ME ASK A QUESTION I
WAS GOING TO ASK BUT IT BUT IT
COMES FROM THAT I KNOW GOVERNOR
BROWN WAS COMPLETELY
EXASPERATED WITH THIS AGENCY A
BECAUSE HE NEVER FELT LIKE THEY
IN
DO HAVE THIS IN FRONT OF YOU.
ISSUES ARE NOT NEW. IT COMING
IN FRONT OF YOU WILL NOT BE
NEW. WILL YOU BE ABLE TO ACT
EXPEDITIOUSLY OPERA ON A
PROJECT IF IT COMES IN FRONT OF
YOU IN A WAY THAT. THAT YOU CAN
APPLY THE SCIENCE AT ALL THE
ROUND TABLES YOU JUST TALKED
ABOUT TO JUST ARE ACTING ON
THIS IN THE NEXT. BUT DISHES
WHY EITHER WHY YOU ACT ON IT. I
HOPE SO. SENATOR I- YEAH I WILL
NEVER BE THE MOST HAVE. EXPERTS
WERE KNOWLEDGEABLE PERSON AT
THIS TABLE. OF EXPERTS
SCIENTISTS OTHERS. AND TERMS OF
THE PROTECT TECHNICAL ASPECTS
OF IT. BUT I DID LEARN OVER THE
YEARS TO BE DECISIVE I LEARNED
THE VALUE. OF MAKING A DECISION
THAT THERE'S NEVER A PERFECT
DECISION. BUT THE WORST
DECISION YOU CAN MAKE IS TO
JUST KEEP PUTTING SOMETHING
OFF- AND I KNOW THAT THAT'S-
ENDEMIC IN GOVERNMENT BUT- I
CAN JUST GIVE MY PERSONAL
PLEDGE THAT I WILL BE PUSHING
FOR DECISIVE ACTION. AND DIED
AND YOU KNOW. TIME TELL WELL I
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
SERVE AND AS- SOMEBODY THAT
FLUNKING RETIREMENT I JUST SAY
WELCOME TO THE CLUB. THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED I'M GONNA GO TO SENATOR
BATES NOW GO AHEAD SENATOR.
THANK YOU AND JOE-
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR STEPPING INTO THEIR PHONE
WE HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION
EARLIER IN THE DAY VERY
IMPRESSED WITH THE FACT THAT
YOU ARE IDENTIFIED TO TRY TO
VERTICAL LEARNING CURVE ON THE
F. BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO BE OF
WHAT HAPPENS TO ALL OF US WE
JUMP INTO SOME OF THESE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN. AROUND FOR
QUITE AWHILE AND YOU'VE HEARD
THE DISCUSSION EARLIER ON
ENERGY FILL- CERTAINLY THE
DELTA CONVEYANCE PROJECT HAS
BEEN THERE FOR QUITE AWHILE AND
I THINK OF THE ON THE COUNCIL
HERE. MISTER COUNSELORS
BASICALLY. REQUIRED TO DEVELOP
A DELTA PLAN SO I JUST HAVE A
ONE QUESTION FOR YOU WHETHER.
THE CONVEYANCE PROJECT ACTUALLY
MAKES IT IF IT FAILS TO GET ALL
AND OUT NECESSARY REGULATORY
APPROVALS. IS THERE A PLAN B.
OUT THERE THAT YOU OF YOU KNOW
BEEN BRIEFED ON. IS EVEN
SOMETHING DISCUSS THE THAT
WOULD BE IN PLACE TO ENSURE AND
IMPROVE WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY. BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT FINANCIALLY WITH YOU KNOW
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT ATTHE
SAME TIME PROTECTING THE APPLE
SYSTEM THAT. WATER RELIABILITY
AS YOU'VE MENTIONED ESPECIALLY
FOR VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IS
REALLY. SUCH A HIGH PRIORITY
AND I KNOW THAT IS FOR YOU SO.
OFTEN FAR FROM THAT. THANK YOU
ADVICE SERVICE AND THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR BEING SO GENEROUS
WITH YOUR TIME IN OUR OUR
EARLIER CONVERSATION. I'M SORRY
AGAIN THE COUNCIL SUPPORTS
CONVEYANCE- WE BELIEVE THAT
NEEDS TO BE A PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE THE JUROR. THIS IS PART
OF YOUR QUESTION- YOUR
HYPOTHETICAL QUESTION OF WHAT
IF THAT PIECE OF PUZZLE MISSING
I GUESS WE WOULD. HAVE TO RELY
EVEN MORE ON THE OTHER PIECES
WHICH IS WE'RE GONNA NEED WITH
OR WITHOUT COMPLAINTS. BUT
PREFERABLY WITH- AND THAT IS I
THINK YOU ALL KNOW IS WE HAVE
TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
CONSERVATION I KNOW PEOPLE GET
TIRED OF HEARING IT BUT WE
ACTUALLY CAN'T BETTER AND MUST.
A CONSERVATION STORAGE HAS TO
BE PART OF THAT THAT PUZZLE
WHEN I SPOKE ABOUT THAT EARLIER
YEAH SENATOR BATES INDEED IT
DOES IT'S SORT OF THE- IT'S
TAKEN A LOT OF. MONEY IN THE
BANK- AS AS SITUATION MORE
VOLATILE. HI THIS YEAR SALLY IS
ANOTHER CASE IN POINT. OF HOW
UNRELIABLE PRECIPITATION IS IN
THE STATE. MAYBE LOOKING AT
SOMETHING AS BAD AS- WILL
REMEMBER TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE. WATER STORAGE
SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE HAVE TO
DO A BETTER JOB OF- AND YOU
KNOW AGAIN IT HABITAT
RESTORATION THAT THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL PIECE OF THIS IS
IMPORTANT TOO BECAUSE WITH OR
WITHOUT TO DANCE- WE HAVE TO
GET OUR ECOSYSTEMS IN BETTER
SHAPE RESTORATION AND
PROTECTION. IF WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A ALLOW WATER SUPPLY BUT
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL BE
ALONGSIDE SOME VERSION OF
CONVENIENCE I DON'T KNOW I
DON'T HAVE IN MY HEAD BUT THAT
SHOULD OR WILL LOOK LIKE AGAIN
I THINK THAT HELD THE TITLE BE
THE DETAILS BUT- BUT- BUT I
HOPE. IT'S IT'S ALL OF THE
ABOVE I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO SEE ALL OF THE ABOVE
APPROACH. THANK YOU AND AGAIN
I'M VERY IMPRESSED AND I'M-
VERY HIGHLY SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
APPOINTMENT TO THIS POSITION
ESPECIALLY ON OUR EARLIER
CONVERSATION AND WHAT YOU
SHARED. IN TERMS OF YOUR
PRIORITIES AND I THINK THAT.
YOU'RE THE PERFECT PERSON. TO
BE THERE IN TERMS OF. DEALING
WITH THIS STORAGE IS YOU AND-
SENATOR HERTZBERG YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY
DAYS. WE HAD A BIG- BLOCKADE ON
VOTING FOR THE BUDGET IF YOU
REMEMBER THAT. IT WAS A TWO
THIRDS VOTE IN THOSE DAYS. AND
THE REPUBLICANS WERE VERY
RECALCITRANT THEY WEREN'T GOING
TO GO THERE AND THEY ON. OUR
LEADERS AND I THINK BOB MIGHT
HAVE BEEN A PART OF THAT ON THE
OTHER SIDE. I'VE GOT GOVERNOR
GRAY DAVIS TO AGREE TO TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OR STORAGE
AND NOW WITH A BIG. HEART
ISSUE. AND THAT THAT BOTTLES
VOTE SO IT GOES WAY BACK TO
THAT WAS IN 200-012-0002 SOME.
SOMETHING IN THAT SAME. DAY SO
IT CONTINUES TO BE AN ISSUE AND
I KNOW THAT. THAT IS DEFINITELY
OFF ON YOUR PLAN SO. YOU HAVE
MY- FIVE FIVE AND MY
ENDORSEMENT TO WHEN WE GET TO
THE BILL AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. I REALLY.
ENJOYED OUR CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BATES
I'M HONORED TO HAVE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SENATOR- MISTER
MAJORITY LEADER. THANK YOU
AGAIN JUST FOR THE RECORD I.
JUST GOT A POTENTIAL ISSUES
THAT I WANT TO DISCLOSE. FIRST
OF ALL- V. APPOINTEES PARTNER
WAS A NEIGHBOR OF MINE MORE
THAN FIFTY YEARS AGO JACKIE
SUPPLE HE WAS KNOWN AS IN THOSE
DAYS AND- HIS FATHER WAS MY
DOCTOR. AND HIS SISTER ASKED ME
TO THE CITY HAWKINS DANCE. SO I
WILL TELL YOU THANK GOODNESS
YOU'VE DISCLOSED THIS. MADAM
CHAIR THAT I'M SURE COULD I
HAVE A POINT OF PERSON. I WAS
VERY SURPRISED TO FIND OUT THAT
THE FATHER THAT WAS YOUR DOCTOR.
WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL WITH MY
FATHER IT ELEANOR AND I
PRODUCED A YEAR BOOK OF HIS
FATHER WRITING A NOTE TO MY
FATHER SO I'VE GOT TO BY TEN OR
FIFTEEN YEARS ALL. ALL I CAN
SAY IS SENATOR BATES TOP THAT.
I ALSO WANT TO DISCLOSE THAT MY
FORMER SPOUSE HIRED YOU AWAY
FROM MARIA SHRIVER SUPPOSEDLY
FOR YOUR CALIFORNIA DIAMOND
EVER SOLD WITH THAT ON THE
RECORD WE'LL GET TO THE
SUBSTANCE. OF IT AND AGAIN
TALKING ABOUT FORMERS I WANTED
TO DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO
YOUR FORMER BOSS. GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER UP BECAUSE AS
YOU WELL KNOW FROM THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH HIM. AT THE
ISSUE THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT IN
YOUR OPENING WITH RESPECT TO
LEVEES WAS QUITE IMPORTANT AND
YOU KNOW SOME MILLIONS MEASURE
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE. THE
DELTA REFORM ACT. ARE CALLED ON
THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL
TO LEAD A MULTI AGENCY EFFORT
TO UPDATE PRIORITIES FOR STATE
INVESTMENTS IN THE DELTA LEVEE
SYSTEM. THE MAJORITY LEADER
OFTEN TALKED ABOUT THAT ISSUE
WHICH YOU REFERRED TO AND
CERTAINLY OUR DATA SHOWS THAT
RECENT COST ESTIMATES WE DID
ISSUE A ONE POINT THREE TO
THREE BILLION DOLLARS TO DEAL
WITH THOSE. ISSUES THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT. JUST WANTED TO
GET ANY THOUGHTS YOU HAD IN
THAT REGARD GIVEN SO IT DID YOU
CORRECT CORRECTLY. NOTED HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS. THANK YOU
FOR A EMPHASIZING THAT.
MAJORITY HERTZBERG AND. AND I
THINK YOU KNOW YOU
CHARACTERISTICALLY NAILED IT
THE CORE ISSUE THIS IS A
RESOURCE QUESTION I MEAN AND
RESOURCES I MEAN MONEY. IF
WE'RE IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT.
PROTECTING YEAH I MENTIONED
THAT IF THE PEOPLE IN THE DELTA
REGION ARE AT RISK OF
CONSEQUENCES SERIOUS FLOODING
IN YEARS AHEAD- THERE IT'S
GOING TO TAKE INVESTMENT
RESOURCES AND THAT'S BEYOND THE
PURVIEW OF THE DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AS YOU
KNOW. BUT I HAVEN'T AND I'VE
BEEN ASKING EVERYONE I'M HAVE
THE LUXURY NOW BEING EXPOSED TO
THE EXPERTS ON ALL SIDES OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS. I HAVEN'T
GOT AN ANSWER YET THAT DOESN'T
INVOLVE SOME MAJOR EXPENDITURES
SO I WOULD SECOND SALE WISE
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT COMPLICATES
THINGS FOR EVERYONE BUT WHAT
I'M JUST YEAH. MYSTERIES IS
BECAUSE OF YOUR EXPERTISE AND
YOUR EXPERIENCE IN RELATIONSHIP
CONSERVING FOR GOVERNORS I
WOULD JUST TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU ARE ALLOWED VOICE YOU
KNOW SO OFTEN IN GOVERNMENT
TEXAS IS CERTAINLY LEARNED THAT
JUST RECENTLY. WE HAVE SOME
CATASTROPHE REPORTS WRITTEN WE
TALK ABOUT IT AND THEN NOTHING
HAPPENS BECAUSE JUST EVERY WEEK
THERE'S A NEW PROBLEM THAT
DEMANDS OUR ATTENTION. AND THE
GOOD GOVERNANCE GOOD GOVERNMENT
EXCUSE ME R. REQUIRES THAT WE
STAY VIGILANT AND THAT WE PLAN
FOR THESE THINGS IN ADVANCE OF
THE DON'T BECOME CATASTROPHES
AND CERTAINLY. YOU LOOK AT ALL
THE RISK THAT YOU'RE KEENLY
AWARE OF I WOULD JUST CONTINUE
TO BE A LOUD VOICE AND I JUST
TELL YOU YOU HAVE A- STRONG
SUPPORTER AND SOMEONE WHO.
ALTHOUGH I REPRESENT THAT
PORTION OF THE STATE IS AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE RESOURCES
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY JUST READ A STORY
TODAY ABOUT THE DROUGHT THE
NUMBERS SO WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN
THE PERCENTAGES OF DELIVERY
THAT. IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
IT'S QUITE CHALLENGING AND
WE'VE GOT TO BALANCE THAT OUT
SO. I JUST WANT TO ASK YOU TO
STAY STRONG ON THAT ISSUE
BECAUSE IT AND USE YOUR
LEVERAGE YOUR RELATIONSHIPS- TO
HELP IN THAT REGARD THAT'S ONLY
THING I WILL TAKE THAT TO
HEART. THANK YOU MAJORITY
LEADER THANK YOU US SENATOR I
WOULD JUST. ADD TO THIS THIS IS
BEEN- NOT ONLY AN INTERESTING
CONVERSATION BUT- CERTAINLY A
FUN ONE- YOU KNOW REPRESENTING
SO DIEGO WHICH IS ALL THE WAY
IF YOU OTHER- IN. OF THE STATE.
BOB PEOPLE HAVE A- ABOUT. THE
CO EQUAL GOALS AND CONVEYANCE-
AS YOU'RE QUITE AWARE AND- YOU
KNOW I'M REALLY PROUD OF THE
DIVERSIFIED PORTFOLIO AND I
KNOW THAT SENATOR BATES UP IN
ORANGE COUNTY IS AWARE. OF THE
APPROACH WE'VE TAKEN AND SAN
DIEGO CONSERVATION IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. AND WE'VE
DONE A PRETTY GOOD JOB STORAGE
IS A PIECE OF OUR- PORTFOLIO.
OF PURE WATER WATER RE USE AND
DIESEL ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE
PART OF OUR- DIVERSIFICATION TO
TRY TO HELP THE MASTER. PLAN
STATEWIDE BUT- WE ALSO HAVE
FOLKS WHO ARE VERY ONCERNED
ABOUT THE- ECOLOGY AND
CERTAINLY- PROTECTION OF THE
DELTA FOR OTHER REASONS SO I
ALWAYS FIND IT AT A REALLY
INTERESTING CONVERSATION TO
TALK ABOUT THE DELTA. AND ITS
CONNECTION TO THE REST OF THE
STATE- SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
BALANCED APPROACH I REALLY
ENJOYED A SENATOR LAYERS
COMMENTS ABOUT- TO BE HONEST I
MEAN IT'S REALLY TRUE THE
BALANCED APPROACH BECAUSE
YOU'VE HAD TO COME FROM BOTH
PARTS OF. THE CONVERSATION ON
THIS AND I DID NOT KNOW YOUR
HISTORY ATTACHED TO THE DELTA
BUT- I THINK IT IT LIVES IN TO
THE- WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO
APPROACH THIS- FROM A MUCH
BROADER PERSPECTIVE SO I ENJOY
THE QUESTIONS I DON'T I DON'T
REALLY HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OTHER THAN THE
COMMENTS WHICH IS I COULD AGREE
MORE WITH- SENATOR BATES- HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS AND I DON'T
USUALLY SAY THAT IN ADVANCE OF
THE- PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I. I
THINK WE'RE WE'RE FORTUNATE
THAT WHILE YOU ARE. VERY HUMBLY
I TALKED ABOUT YOUR- MAYBE LOOK
LACK OF DEEP. SCIENTIFIC
KNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT. YOU
HAVE A CRITICAL WAY OF THINKING
ABOUT THIS AND A BROAD
PERSPECTIVE. MAKES ME FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE SO- AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON FORTY YEARS-
I WILL JUST SAY CATARACTS-
WE'RE GOING TO YOU DO YOU ONE
MORE THING- CENTER MOVED WE
ALWAYS. THE PUBLIC IS WAITING
FOR THIS AND- I. IT'S ALL GOOD-
I AM GOING TO GO TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT AND- STARTED
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I
DO NOT SEE ANYONE FROM THE
PUBLIC TO SPEAK SO I'M GONNA
LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE. ALSO
NO ONE APPROACHING SO I'M GOING
TO GO BACK TO OUR FABULOUS A.
T. AND T. MODERATOR AND SAY
WELCOME BACK AND- ASK IF YOU
WANT TO QUEUE UP PEOPLE- TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO QUEUE UP FOR SUPPORT IN
A PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THE END IF YOU LIKE TO
COMMENT THE PORT. S. ONE ZERO
THANK YOU AND A REMINDER TO
GIVE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION OF
ANY SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY
FOR OUR STENOGRAPHER AND. WITH
THE ACT GO AHEAD MR MY. AT THE
TIME THERE NO. PARTICIPANT YOU.
OKAY I WILL COME BACK INTO ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AGAIN
RECOGNIZING THAT I DON'T SEE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE
WHO WOULD SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
WE'RE NOW IN OPPOSITION AGAIN
LOOKING AT ROOM ONE TWELVE I
STILL SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SO MISTER MODERATOR I'M
COMING BACK TO YOU. FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT MIGHT BE IN
OPPOSITION. FOR IF YOU LIKE TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND NO
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MISTER MODERATOR- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP AND WITH
THAT I'M GOING TO GO TO-
SENATOR HERTZBERG MR MAJORITY
LEADER FOR THE MOTION SUSIE
AESTHETICALLY MOVE MISTERS AND
GOLLY. THANK YOU. OKAY MADAM
SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
NO MICROPHONES. GROWTH I LOVE
AYE HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
LAYERED AYE AYE BATES RIGHT
IT'S AYE ATKINS I CAN SIGN
CONGRADULATIONS MISTERS AND
GOLLY FIVE ZERO I'M HONORED
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU. LET ME JUST GIVE A
QUICK LOOK ODD TO ARSON AUGER
FOR CAN WE GO ON TO THE LAST
APPOINTMENT ARE YOU GOOD OKAY-
SO WE WILL GO. TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR.
AND MISTER HOLLOWAY JOSEPH JOE
HOLLOWAY JUNIOR CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. CONSERVATION AND
LIQUIDATION OFFICE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE LET ME SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
WELCOME- THIS IS ONE OF THE FEW
APPOINTEES THAT THAT ISN'T A
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE THIS IS AN
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS
APPOINTEE. SO THIS IS A LITTLE
OUT OF THE ORDINARY FOR US BUT
IT'S A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY-
MISTER HOLLOWAY LET ME INVITE
YOU TO- GIVE SOME OPENING
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS RECOGNIZE
ANYBODY YOU WOULD LIKE TO
OPENING COMMENTS AND I'LL GO
RIGHT TO THE SENATORS FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS. WELCOME
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
BLIGHTED THANK THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO INTRODUCE MYSELF AND
DESCRIBE MY QUALIFICATIONS AND
MY VISION FOR THE CONSERVATION
OF LIQUIDATION OFFICE. I'M
HONORED THAT INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER LARA HAS CHOSEN
MADE ARE APPOINTED NAY SCO. AND
MY PRIORITY WILL BE TO ENSURE
THAT OUR OFFICE MAXIMIZES
DISTRIBUTIONS OF ASSETS FROM
INSOLVENT SHARON'S COMPANIES-
TO THE CONSUMERS AN INJURED
WORKERS. AND ALSO TO PARTNER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE AND THE
IDENTIFICATION. AND
INTERVENTION AND TO. REBELDE
INSURANCE COUPLE. I STARTED MY
CAREER BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE WITH THE NORTH CAROLINA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE WORKED
THERE FOR TWENTY YEARS AND A
DEFINING. REBELDE INSURERS AND
TRYING TO REHABILITATE THEM AND
ALSO PROTECT THE CONSUMERS. WHO
HAVE CLAIMS WILL WITH WITH
THOSE PARTIES I STARTED WORKING
WITH THE CONSERVATION
LIQUIDATION OFFICE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR AND SINCE THAT
TIME OUR OFFICE HAS DISTRIBUTED
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
AND INSOLVENT INSURANCE COMPANY
ASSETS. TO CONSUMERS AND
INJURED WORKERS. I APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO- TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MR
MAJORITY LEADER YOU WANNA KICK
US OFF. OKAY IT'S VERY
IMPRESSIVE AND THANK YOU FOR
DOING THE WORK IT'S REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT JOB AND- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
SERVE IN THANK YOU FOR COMING
TO THE- GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE SHOULD WATCH. THE
BOARD SPORTS. THANK YOU-
SENATOR GROWTH. I GUESS I
SHOULD JUST ASK A COUPLE
QUESTIONS SINCE I'M ON A ROLL
TODAY AND THERE'S ABOUT FIFTEEN
STATES THAT CLO. AT CURRENTLY
MANAGES THIRTEEN HAVE BEEN OPEN
FOR LONGER THAN FIFTEEN YEARS
AND SO MY QUESTION I GUESS IS
HE'LL HAVE AN ESTIMATED TIME.
WHEN THOSE THE STATE'S CAN BE
CLOSED AND HOW WILL THE STATE
CLOSURES IMPACT- YOUR WOR
FORCE NEEDS. RIGHT OF THE
FIFTEEN STATES FIVE THOSE ARE A
PART OF ONE GROUP WHICH IS THE
SUPERIOR NATIONAL INSURANCE
COMPANY. WE ARE CLOSING THAT
PARTICULAR ESTATE THIS YEAR AND
WILL DISTRIBUTE THE EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ASSETS- SO
THAT NOW TO BRING OUR PORTFOLIO
DOWN TO TEN COMPANIES AT THAT
POINT. WE HAVE DISTRIBUTIONS
LINED UP FOR THIS YEAR OF
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL- IT WILL
REDUCE OUR PORTFOLIO. OF THE
MAJORITY OF OUR ASSETS THAT
THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY MANAGING
BELONG TO ALL A COMBINATION OF
TEN INSURANCE COMPANIES THAT
ARE ORDER NOW CALLED CASTLE
NATIONAL INSURANCE COMPANY.
THAT IS A RELATIVELY-
INSOLVENCY NOT SAY NEW THAT WAS
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN- WITH
THIS PARTICULAR STATE HAS A LOT
OF WORKERS COMPENSATION CLAIMS
LIABILITY CLAIMS. THAT HAVE TO
BE ADMINISTERED- AND OUR
BIGGEST ASSET IS THE
REINSURANCE THAT. WE COLLECT
AFTER THESE CLAIMS ARE PAID.
AND SO- THAT'LL BE THE FOCUS OF
OUR GREAT FOR THE NEXT SIX OR
SEVEN YEARS. BEFORE ABLE TO
CLOSE OUT THAT PARTICULAR STATE.
THANK YOU SIR VERY MUCH FOR
THAT I APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
ARE CENTER LAYERED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR. ARM I
REALLY ENJOYED OUR MEETING AND-
THE A I THINK YOU
SATISFACTORILY ANSWERED
ANYTHING BUT I THOUGHT THERE
WAS ONE SUBJECT I WOULD LIKE TO
PUT. ON THE RECORD IN AN
EXCHANGE AND IT. IS OBVIOUSLY
HAVING A FIRE BURNED A COUPLE
OF MARKET WITHIN A COUPLE MILES
MY HOUSE THAT TOOK NINE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE HOMES. IS THERE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
STRUGGLING WITH GETTING FIRE
INSURANCE. AND I REMEMBER WHEN
I WAS AT RESOURCES THERE WAS AN
INSURANCE COMPANY. THAT WENT
BELLY UP. OUR WITH PARADISE OF
POLICIES WITHIN WEEKS OF THE
PARADISE FIRE. AND I ASKED YOU
IF YOU THOUGHT THAT WITH THE
ADDITION OFFIRE IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S SUCH A GREAT RATE. THAT
WOULDN'T WE HAVE BIGGER. A
COMPANIES START TO GO WONDER
BECAUSE OF FIRE AND YOU
BASICALLY SAID NO BECAUSE OF
THE REINSURANCE- IT COULD YOU
JUST TALK A LITTLE ABOUT THAT
SO THAT PEOPLE WOULD UNDERSTAND
WHAT THAT DYNAMIC IS. SURE AND-
AND MERCED WAS WAS DEFINITELY A
TRAGEDY- OF UNPRECEDENTED FIRE-
AND ONE THAT. AFTER FURTHER
REVIEW- THE THERE WERE SOME
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT CONCENTRATION. A
NUMBER OF CLAIMS IN A CERTAIN
LOCATION- THE LARGER INSURANCE
COMPANIES WORK WITH THEIR
REINSURERS NOW TO MAP BASICALLY
BY ZIP CODE- WHERE EXACTLY THE
RISK THAT THEY HAVE ARE- AND
THEY THEY PROBABLY PUT THEIR
PRICING TOGETHER BASED ON THAT
YES. AND SO THE LARGER
COMPANIES- BY- ADDITIONAL
LAYERS OF CATASTROPHE INSURANCE
ADJUSTER THAT IF THEY
EXPERIENCE LARGE VOLUMES OF
CLAIMS- FROM A SINGLE BETS FOR
THOSE- THOSE CLAIMS ARE COVERED
BY REINSURANCE THEY PAY THE
CLAIMS AND THEN THE REINSURER
REIMBURSES THEM BASED ON THOSE
CLAIMS. AND IF THERE'S- FAULT
FOUND FOR THE FIRE THEN THAT IS
A DEEP POCKET THAT HELPS KEEP
THE- THE COMPANY'S OF FLOTUS
WELLS AT CORRECT. ABSOLUTELY
THERE I THINK THE TOTAL THAT
WAS PAID ON THE MERCED THE
STATE WAS SEVENTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN CLAIMS AND FIFTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF THAT
SEVENTY NINE BILL HAS BEEN
RECOVERED FROM PG&E. AND THOSE
RECOVERIES ALONG WITH THE CASH
THAT. OUR OFFICE HAS INVESTED
FOR MERCED- WILL IT IF IT IF IT
WON'T MAKE EVERYONE HOLE IT'LL
MAKE EVERYONE. WITHIN 5% OF
WHOLE. THANK YOU THAT'S REALLY
HELPFUL APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSE TO THE QUESTIONS
SENATOR THANKS FOR ASKIN OF
THOSE QUESTIONS THAT WAS REALLY
HELPFUL TO HEAR SENATOR FAITH.
I THANK YOU AND AGAIN MISTER
HOLLOWAY THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
SERVICE AND STEPPING INTO THIS
VERY IMPORTANT RESPONSIBILITY
ARE YOUR RESUMES SPEAKS. HIGHLY
OF YOUR QUALIFICATIONS FOR THE
OFF AND- I THINK WE ALL KNOW
COMMISSIONER LARA. AND I WORKED
WITH HIM ON THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR A COUPLE YEARS
SO I THINK HE'S MADE A GREAT
CHOICE HERE SO LET HIM KNOW
THAT- HI. I AM IMPRESSED WITH
WHAT'S BILLS ARE PARTICULAR
AGENCY HAS DONE EVEN BOTH
OUTSIDE THE LEGISLATURE. OF
BEING ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR AND HE ON BASICALLY
ON A REDUCING OF THE WHAT WAS
CARRIED AT THAT TIME DOWN TO
JUST FIFTEEN IS PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE IN TERMS OF THE WORK
IT IT HAS DONE THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE WORK THAT IS DONE SO- I
HAVE GREAT SUPPORT FOR THE
AGENCY AND CERTAINLY FOR YOUR
APPOINTMENT SO I WILL CERTAINLY
BE SUPPORTING YOU AND- AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR STEPPING UP AND
ACCEPTING THE- NOMINATION TO
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ROLE- IN
THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY. THANK
YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES- I CAN FOR WITH THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES. WITH
THAT- WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. AND
WE'RE GOING TO PUT ON THE
SCREEN AGAIN ARE- PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER. WHICH IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. NINE TWO FOUR
ONE FOUR FIVE EIGHT. SO I'M
GOING TO START HERE IN THIRTY
ONE NINETY ROOF ONE SORRY
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. THERE
ARE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE I'M GOING TO GO TO ONE
TWELVE ROOM ONE TWELVE. I ALSO
SEE NO ONE- WAITING IN THE
QUEUE THERE SO MR MODERATOR I'M
COMING BACK TO YOU TO SEE IF WE
HAVE PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF MR HOLLOWAY. I'M
PAUSING FOR ONE MOMENT YES.
WE'RE HAVING A JUST A TAD BIT
OF TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY MISTER
HOLLOWAY SO- ONE MOMENT.
MISTER
HOLLOWAY WERE JUST HAVING A
LITTLE BIT OF DIFFICULTY WITH
OUR TELECOMMUNICATION OR
TELECONFERENCE- A. T. T.
OPERATOR WERE TRYING TO GET
THEM BACK ONLINE MOMENTARILY SO
PLEASE FORGIVE US AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. HELLO.
LET
ME ASK OUR MODERATOR ON
TELECONFERENCE IF YOU CAN HEAR
US IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE AND
COULD HEAR US. YES I CAN HEAR
THE AUDIO WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
SO WE HAVE ALREADY PUT THE
NUMBER UP ON SCREEN AND- IF
WE'RE ABLE TO PROCEED MISTER
MODERATOR ALL COME TO YOU TO
SEE IF THERE ARE PEOPLE.
WAITING IN THE QUEUE TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF MISTER HOLLOWAY. DO
YOU LIKE TO QUEUE UP AND- IN
THE QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR I'M GONNA COME BACK
INTO ROOM. THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE OUR TO SEE- AND AGAIN- I
SEE THAT THERE'S NO ONE HERE
FOR THE PUBLIC- TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO MR HOLLOWAY IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. I
AM QUICKLY LOOKING IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE AND I SEE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE THERE TO SPEAK SO MISTER
MODERATOR WHILE YOU'RE STILL
WITH US I'M COMING BACK TO YOU
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE FROM THE PUBLIC TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. TO MR HOLLOWAY.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. FOR NO
PARTICIPANT IN Q. MISTER
MODERATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR ASSISTANCE TODAY WE
APPRECIATE IT HAVE A GOOD
EVENING. LET ME COME BACK INTO
THE- COMMITTEE ROOM AND ASK FOR
A MOTION FOR MISTER HOLLOWAY. I
WILL RECOGNIZE SENATOR ROVE OD
TO MAKE THE MOTION AND SHE DID
SO- ADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CALL THE ROLL. AND IF
YOU'LL TURN YOUR MICROPHONE
SOMEONE. GROWTH I ASKED
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
LAYERED AYE AYE AT A BATES ALL
RIGHT BATES AYE ATKINS AYE
ATKINS FIVE ZERO FIVE TO ZERO
MISTER HOLLOWAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH IT'S UNANIMOUS AND-
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO LOOK FORWARD TO THE
WORK THANK YOU. OKAY LET ME
JUST FINALLY- SAY THANK YOU TO
ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED- IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN OUR OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD. SO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE YOUR COOPERATION IT
WAS AN ENJOYABLE CROP
CONVERSATION ON SEVERAL FRONTS
TODAY. AND WITH THAT THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES ONE NOW
MOVES INTO CLOSED SESSION THANK
YOU.